okay good morning everybody we'll get
being 9 35
i'm gonna open the public hearing on
house bill 1401 prohibiting the
disclosure of the number of miles driven
by a specific driver licensed by the
state or vehicle registered in the state
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
it was on was that
thank you mr chair thank you members of
the committee for hearing my testimony
for the record my name is
keith ammon and i represent hillsborough
district 40 and that's the towns of new
boston mount vernon milford and hollis
and i'm here today to introduce house
you may be aware that in 2018
our state passed a privacy amendment
to our state constitution and it shored
up the natural right of citizens to
have privacy in their
in their
their information is one aspect of that
and over 80 percent of our population
entire state voting population voted for
that constitutional amendment
in this
term of our legislature
there are several attempts to try to
shore up
[Music]
that amendment in statute so you could
consider house bill 1401
to be part of that
effort what house bill 1401 does is it
adds the miles driven
in a motor vehicle
to that privacy protection
and the
part of the intent of the bill
is to
keep our citizens mileage data
within our within our state uh borders
and to not go
to the federal government
so that's the intent of the bill
now why do that now
[Music]
uh
the under the biden administration the
the the secretary of transportation uh
secretary butter judge
has discussed implementing a nationwide
mileage tax
which would be something brand new
doesn't exist before
and uh
that was floated uh
in the early part of last year
in the 1.2 trillion dollar
infrastructure bill
there's a pilot program that's buried in
that massive bill to to
to research the federal government doing
just that
and so this
so the federal government is floating a
trial balloon
and the intent of this bill is to pop
that balloon
in when it comes to the state of new
hampshire
preserving our citizens privacy privacy
when it comes to the miles that they
drive
the intent of the bill is not to disrupt
uh the title process in our state
it's not to disrupt um
you know
the trucking industry and any kind of
regulations that
surround that
and it's not to disrupt any business
models that might depend on mileage data
that uh
that that the state would uh oversee
so it's not to disrupt anything that
that's existing the intent is to
pop that trial balloon about a new
national mileage tax
i believe that the committee received an
email from the company carfax and we're
probably familiar with
carfax they have a fox as a mascot
so that company reached out to me their
government relations
officer reached out to me and we worked
on
the language of that amendment
that would protect their business model
they rely on mileage data but they don't
they don't attach that mileage data to
uh an individual it's only to the vin
number of a vehicle is what i found out
and so uh you have that
that amendment in your inbox
now
the precedent of
a law being put in place that would
uh preempt a federal program
uh
this is not a new precedent that that
precedent has been set on several
occasions
with real id
uh years ago
the the transportation uh secretary has
also floated uh in he gave a press
release a few days ago
about having zero traffic deaths i don't
know if you heard that speech by him but
he would like to reach a goal of zero
traffic deaths one of the way that one
of the ways that they propose to do that
would be to implement a nationwide
camera system on on our nation's roads
so
it would be a camera system that would
track you know speed license plate all
those things and try to minimize
traffic deaths through such a program
that program under rsa 261 colon 110
is illegal currently in the state of new
hampshire by statute so that would be a
precedent where
our state has the ability to put laws in
place to prevent
you know a new program that might be
overreach into our state
and with that i'll take any questions
thank you sir any questions from the
committee representative telersky
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question um
i understand your intent is to
stop this potential future federal
issue as you've explained but in my uh
handful of days subbing on public works
committee i've also understood the
impact
of the
highway fund and the
road toll and the ways we're going to
have to address
the funds to manage our roads in the
coming years with the higher efficiency
vehicles
and uh
electric vehicles etc and i know that
mileage is a very
important factor in that discussion
don't you believe that if this bill went
into law it would actually it would also
prevent the state from using that
information to address our revenue
concerns in terms of the road toll
thank you for your question
so tolls
you're charged a toll when you pass a
certain
location right
may clarify
sorry i i was gonna just okay sorry go
ahead so a toll is not based on mileage
of totals based on you passing a certain
point in physical space so
tolls will not be affected
uh
this bill
i'll admit this bill is not in its final
form
if the state would like to implement a
mileage tax to cover high efficiency
vehicles or electric vehicles
i would be open to amending this to make
to clarify that the state would be able
to do that but
what we don't want to do is expose our
citizens to a whole new
taxing scheme by the federal government
um one thing i did see on the back here
is that they can't disclose the mileage
without consent of the vehicle's owner
but i don't see any provision for some
sort of a form that
the owner would have to fill out to
disclose that information and i can see
that being a quagmire down the road
oh they didn't realize what they were
doing and now they don't want that
disclosed
yeah that's a good point
um and perhaps if the department's going
to speak after me they could address
that a lot of times
we're discouraged from putting the the
specific language of a form into statute
and to leave that to the rule-making
process so that would be you know my
best guess and answer to that okay thank
you further questions from the committee
representative gorski thank you mr
chairman and thank you representative
taking my question
the you mentioned the nationwide mileage
task if tax that
commissioner budojig was thinking about
putting in if that ever got into place
what is what would be that tax
well
it
remains to be seen the exact amount but
the amount that was floated early last
year was eight cents per mile so
so you could imagine
a couple different scenarios you go to
get your car inspected they record your
mileage
and the the government requires the
federal or the inspection station to
send that data to the federal government
they they difference year over year
multiply by eight cents
um
not not to get too far into the future
but a lot of these electric vehicles are
connected to the internet uh they have
location data that you know they even
have cameras all the way around if
you've ever driven in a tesla there's
cameras all around because they use
those cameras to
you know sense other vehicles and the
road conditions
um but the geolocation data
being streamed to the internet as you
drive would be another way in in the not
too distant future that that data could
be collected and and you could be
automatically taxed on it so we'd want
to you know think ahead and figure out
how we can
use our
authority as the legislature of a state
to maybe shield our citizens from
something coming in the future like that
thank you
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
uh next up
uh looks like
tell me if i'm pronouncing this wrong
priscilla van from the department of
safety department of motor vehicles
my name is priscilla vaughn i work for
the department of safety been there for
40 years
i work for the title and anti-theft
this bill
i feel like there's a lot of
holes in the bill it needs it really
needs to be looked at because the way i
read it that the department of safety
can't record any mileage and we have a
lot of federal laws that we go through
uh the federal odometer tampering law
we also have
the
truth and mileage act
one of them has been around since 1972
the other has been around since 1986.
this is very important information to
transfer the owner has to transfer the
mileage on the back of the title
for every vehicle that they sell
this is also reported to the national
system
which is nimbitus and that is federally
funded
or federally mandated by the feds
i'm concerned with the fact that
the wording states that we can't
transfer that information to the
department of safety
it's very open
there's a federal
lots of federal laws out there that come
up to play
my big concern is the fact that
if my daughter or granddaughter is
buying a car
and
there's an odometer statement that says
20 000 miles and they have bald tires
what does that tell you you should have
good tires on a vehicle if it has 20 000
miles on it should have original tires
so i look at it like
there could be odometer fraud when i
look through the odometer fraud statutes
online you can look online and see all
that there's 450 000 vehicles a year
that
have been tampered with and that's a
billion dollar fraud industry and if you
look at that
it's going to increase i believe if we
don't keep track of the federal odometer
act
it's our duty to make sure that we have
safe vehicles on the road and
with that said this this bill definitely
needs some work because it there's a lot
of holes in my opinion it doesn't talk
to the fact that it would protect
the people who selling cars uh
that's the dealers
the insurance companies there's a lot of
people involved here there's a lot of
stakeholders that depend on that when
you buy a car
that value of that vehicle determines
the
the mileage that's on the vehicle if you
see a vehicle that's 200 000 miles
you're not going to pay top dollar for
that vehicle if it has 20 000 miles
you know you're gonna pay top dollar so
it's just a lot to think about um
and that's the state's position does
anyone have any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative sykes
yes do we have any state data that
relative to the i mean those numbers
that you gave us were federal
numbers i assume
i have the federal government is the one
that
pursues those um and i don't have any
stats on hand of any any odometer fraud
i'm sure i could dig some up if i had to
we have a lot of cases i've done over
the 40 years i've worked with odometer
fraud
follow-up yeah just
with the chair's permission if we could
get that that would be helpful it would
be helpful whatever you can find okay no
problem uh representative o'hara thank
you mr chairman thank you for taking my
question um
the information that you report right
now federally is it just the mileage and
the vin or do you associate a name with
it
so everything the state reports is by
vehicle that mileage follows the vehicle
it doesn't follow a person so i could
buy your car and you need to disclose
that mileage so i can give you the fair
price for that vehicle uh that this
privacy is not really where this belongs
because privacy is your like your
driver's record your photograph your
social security
your personal information a vehicle's
mileage is not your personal information
that is the vehicle's description just
like any brands or flood damage or
anything to do with a vehicle that is
what that's all about
yeah thank you um so if we were able to
make it an amendment to
not associate a person to the mileage
yes
thank you
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much you're
welcome
next up the chair recognizes
jim haydem
state farm
thank you
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee yes for the record my name is
jim haydem i'm here on behalf of state
farm insurance companies
state farm is the one of the nation's
largest and perhaps new hampshire's
largest right of automobile insurance
and for that reason they asked me to
come in and
take a look at this bill and frankly
hear what the testimony is beforehand
and comment on it and
i think i might be the only person
speaking on behalf of the stakeholders
uh in this bill and i i thank the
sponsor for recognizing that
um there are business models that could
be disrupted by this bill and he and i
appreciate his intent not to try to
disrupt him
but i wanted to mention that state farm
is one of many stakeholders that feels
that this well state farm feels that
this bill would have
significant impact on
its practices
and
in the current law you know there's a
clear exception that allows
insurance companies to use this type of
information mileage in the context of
insurance and specifically fraud
activities rating and underwriting
and state farm uses this information to
try to make the interaction with its
customers more seamless
by
populating information and making
judgments on your renewal premiums and
things like that so that when you get
your bill to renew your policy every
year
they can feel comfortable that it has
the most accurate information
behind that
behind that bill behind that premium
request
and you know if to deny them this
information would require the customer
to provide the information themselves
it's a step this is an annoyance that
most customers don't like that's just
one one of the more practical
applications of this
the other is they use it in rating which
is their determination of what
premium should be charged for any
particular driver any particular vehicle
and this is not only true in relation to
the rating of the particular individuals
but when they try to get their rates
approved at the insurance department
they need to prove that they're sound
based on actuarial principles and
mileage relating to vehicles is one
factor that goes into many many factors
when they go in to get their rates
approved so again i thank
the sponsor for recognizing
that
excuse me that state farm and others
have legitimate interest in this
information and
to the extent this committee
would like to see this bill go forward
i'd appreciate an opportunity to
comment on
thank you very much question from the
committee
representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
it's basically a follow-up to the last
question i just asked if we're able to
make the distinction between
the person and not the vehicle because
i'm assuming state farm uses the vin to
get the mileage not hurt the person's
name
would stay farm be able to with that
disruptive business
representative thank you i was actually
trying to figure out my answer that
question when you asked it last and i
don't have a good answer for you but
i could certainly get it if you'd like
could you thank
you uh any other questions from the
committee
representative thank you thank you for
taking my question this is just more out
of curiosity um when you
just either approve someone's request
for insurance do you
not take in to account the driver the
person themselves and their driving
history and
um
if they use their car regularly for work
or that kind of thing i guess i'm just
trying to see the tie between
you offering insurance to a driver and
the fact that it's innately tied to the
person
well certainly the driver record is is
part of the determination of
you know the premium that would be
charged for for an insurance policy also
relevant is the car right and i think
that's where the mileage uh the mileage
comes in because you're trying to price
based upon the value of the car and
so rather than being associated with
the person i think it with
insurance it's more associated with the
car
okay thank you
any other questions
seeing them thank you very much thank
you
chair recognizes jeff oberdenk from
department of motor vehicles
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
jeff obernank and i'm here really today
we didn't have a position initially
um
wasn't really sure where the bill was
headed or what it was about until we
heard the introduction
a little while ago
one of the things that we want to be
aware of is that there are instances in
which we use mileage
for several different programs that we
have
and one of those such things is the low
mileage waiver
for somebody who passes the safety
inspection but fails
the obd inspection and drives less than
we collect that mileage in order to
determine if they're eligible for that
program or not
so there is a program out there that we
are using the mileage for
there's also one of the things that we
when we reached out to our vendor gordon
darby with regard to the inspection
process and why they
would grab and track mileage one of
those is relative to almost every brand
new vehicle
anything less than a thousand miles on
it will probably not pass obd for the
simple reason that the sensors haven't
been used enough
so they're tracking the reason why that
they're passing
a vehicle through the service
without it getting a passing grade so
for instance if i buy a car off the lot
that's got 100 miles on it
the oxygen sensors aren't going to tell
me whether it's running well or not
because it hasn't run long enough
so
i'm not yet another reason why we track
mileage
and also mechanics use the mileage
during the inspection process as well
to let a customer know that there may be
a potential issue before the next
inspection
or
so for instance you you roll in that the
car's got 32 000 miles on it and the you
know the inspection mechanic would note
that before you get to 35 or 36 000
miles you're probably going to need
brakes or exhaust or tires or those
things
so not understanding what the bill was
for we went back and we looked at all of
the areas in which we would track
mileage for the inspection process and
we think we have some valid reasons for
having mileage
having said that i'll take any questions
the committee may have
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative thompson
the obd system that's been in place
since 96
that's a that's a great question i think
it has and um
so we've been collecting this
information since 1996.
have we had any
issues with privacy or that you're aware
of nothing that i'm aware of in that
material to be fair nothing that i'm
aware of i i assume the post and
overseeing the inspection program
in september of 2020 so um
in my
past 15 18 months i have not seen
anything
thank you very much
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
and that is the last person i have
signed up to speak is anybody else here
wishing to do so
seeing none i have a question for the
original sponsor again
sure
uh
representative ammon
thank
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
i'm wondering
whether
um because this would be tracked by the
vehicle
would how would it work with um with
someone that uh
that leases or
probably more importantly rents vehicles
presumably
there would be a charge that would come
through
attached to the rental
of a vehicle that you would
be paying for that portion of the of the
mileage driven is that is that how you
anticipate that working
uh that's a good question um i was
thinking mainly of uh
you know people that primarily are
owners of the vehicle
uh i i'll have to think about that if
you have ideas i'd love to
sure thank you very much
sorry about that no no that's why we go
through this process we go through this
process exactly thank you so
any other questions or anybody else
wishing to speak seeing none i'm going
to close the public hearing on house
bill 1401
protectors
call together
house bill 1301
prime sponsor representative walsh
you are up
thirteen forty one
oh
you've got an extra card over there
we'll try it again
1341.
thank you mr chair uh for the record my
name is tom walsh representative from
the town of hooksett um i'm here
introducing house bill 1341 today
at the request of the department of
motor vehicles i put this in it's
relative to the definition of conviction
in title 21 or our motor vehicle laws
i think they can do a much better job
explaining this one
this is the last bill so you know that i
have introduced as a courtesy
so i'll defer all questions to the
department i believe they're already
signed up
next we have britney shoot
dmv
good morning members of the committee
brittany from the division of motor
vehicles
this bill is at the request of the
department
it broadens the definition for a
conviction
currently the way the law is written
it's very specific to
commercial vehicle statutes and the
definitions of convictions
do not really have
they're not defined for regular
operators
this is in the interest of public safety
so we can have better comprehensive more
concise records by being able to
accurately reflect the information that
is received both
in-state and from out-of-state
jurisdictions
with that i'll be happy to take any
questions
seeing none oh i say they can't be that
easy
all right go ahead
sorry i didn't want to
i feel like i just need a little bit
more to absorb here
can you explain to me
uh line three in the bill that whole
section that's being taken out there
sure i think and how it relates to this
line three of
the current legislation that is more
non-commercial convictions by striking
it through line three and line four it
is then listed down below
may i have a follow-up please mr
chairman thank you
um and
just to clarify the fact that this says
now in statute
this section
calling out commercial drivers only by
taking it out you're just opening up to
all drivers on the road correct thank
you
i'm good
yes you are
any more questions from the committee
i take these things off
okay you're all set thank you thank you
i don't see any other cards here for
testimony anybody in the audience would
if not i will now close
okay being 10 12 i'm going to open up
the public hearing on house bill 1302
fn relative to the weighing of vehicles
the chair recognizes as soon as he's
ready the prime sponsor representative
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee for hearing me today i'm
representative stephen smith sullivan
county district 11 ackworth charlestown
goshen langdon webster and washington
uh this bill i discovered when
researching another issue for someone
and was shocked shocked to find that the
state police can pull me over
order me to go to portable scale
somewhere and weigh my car
i've driven over a million miles uh ten
years ago i stopped keeping track
and i've never had police in any state
including new hampshire where i drive
five six hundred miles a week asked me
to go have my car weighed so it seemed
like an opportunity to get rid of an
obsolete law
uh commercial vehicles still have to
pull into the stops but if i have gone
to home depot and put a bunch of two by
fours in the back of my station wagon i
don't have to go to the rest uh to the
way station and that's all the bill does
i'm happy to take questions
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
representative hill thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so what was the purpose of the
of the bill originally why
why was that put in place and
do you have any idea i'm not that old i
don't know um
[Laughter]
the statute had some pretty old
notations on it if i had to guess um
it was just generic language that was
put in when we decided that trucks
needed to be weighed so why not just say
vehicles
and and really
if i've been pulled over and the
officer's concern is wait
i'll bet you there's a bunch of other
things he can cite me for
thank you follow-up
yeah follow-up um
that brings up uh the question so what
what presumably happens if you are
pulled over and they do weigh your car
what are there a list of
of
charges that can come from that weight
or
i
i don't know it's possible if there's
overweight i think any vehicle being
overweight is probably a violation
but um
when
you go down to home depot and pick up
some five gallon pails of driveway
steeler or whatever do you weigh the
occupants of the vehicle and each bucket
that you put in the back no nobody does
that and getting pulled over for it is
dumb
just one question for me so if this were
to pass
um i'm assuming that the guy who has a
f-150 and puts two pallets of shingles
in the back of it wouldn't be able to be
weighed either
two pallets of um well no they can't
order them with scales and i mean are
they doing that now yeah i don't know
that there are generic unsafe load
charges
okay
fair enough
representative fenton uh thank you for
taking my question there's a fiscal note
attached to this it looks like do you
know
for it says less than ten thousand
dollars so it seems like a
straight yeah that's the generic one
they put on when yeah i don't know maybe
we have to change some forms but there's
nothing significant thank you
okay
i i i'd like to be interested to know
who else might be sitting to speak on
this bill because
where i would ask my question
the only one i have left is new
hampshire state police okay fine
you're good okay who will be far better
authorities than i
so seeing no other questions thank you
next up chair recognizes carl huddleston
from the new hampshire state police in
good morning
mr chair and members of the committee
thank you for hearing my testimony
on behalf of the state of new hampshire
department of safety
i
am in opposition of this
i listen to the testimony just given and
i understand and maybe
not understanding how we do things
this may have come about
however
when it comes to just waving somebody in
really reserved for commercial vehicles
only
why i'm in opposition of this is the
question somebody um posed about the two
pallets of shingles in an f-150
there have been some occasions and i
have personally seen this and
stopped somebody who has taken an f-150
f-250
personally owned vehicle and loaded it
to the point where it was
very unsafe
and it becomes an issue of public safety
more than
anything else
so typically
unless we
have probable cause to believe
something
a vehicle is overweight that's a
personal vehicle not a commercial motor
vehicle outside of probable cause we
typically do not pull in
a non-commercial vehicle
without cause
and
the notation on here of the financial
impact being less than ten thousand
dollars i'm the one that actually did
the financial impact statement on this
and
the three years
that i looked back
there had been
um
only a handful of these cases in the
last five years i think there were six
in the last five years that we actually
identified
a non-commercial vehicle as being
overweight the new hampshire statute of
266 colon 26
states that
the vehicle has to be more than 20
percent overweight in order for us to
take any enforcement action against it
so basically a vehicle that was rated
for ten thousand pounds would have to be
over twelve thousand before we actually
were able to write a ticket to it um
a lot of times when we uh identify a
privately owned vehicle a non-commercial
vehicle that is
overweight it's most of the time it's an
educational experience for the operator
and for the trooper more than an
enforcement
type of scenario
we're trying to promote safety uh yes
there are some instances where there is
a citation issued for this
but most of the time
it's the guy on saturday morning trying
to patch his driveway or
he's got two pallets of wood pellets in
the back of this truck and it's headed
down the road this way
so it becomes a public safety issue
more than anything else you're
loading a vehicle well beyond its
capacity
so that's why
we're opposed to adding the language of
only
commercial vehicles to being able to be
weighed
yes sir
questions from the committee
thank you mr chairman thank you sergeant
for taking my question
oh actually it's a request that you
would
elaborate more fully on the pa the uh
the public safety concerns that you have
it's one thing to tell us that the
vehicle is overweight okay but what does
that really mean or what are the impacts
of that for public safety
sure thank you for the question um the
first thing that i would want to talk
about is the braking ability of a
vehicle
loading vehicle 20 percent beyond its
intended
gross vehicle weight rating
significantly
reduces the braking ability of the
vehicle
the steering also becomes less effective
if the vehicle is
overloaded towards the back of the
vehicle like i said somebody riding down
the road
with the vehicle pointing upwards rather
than level takes weight off the the
front axle
making it harder to steer
again
being able to stop
and
being able to control the vehicle once
the vehicle is is overloaded
they tend to wander on the road i think
everybody probably has seen a trailer
behind somebody's car at some point or
truck swaying in
behind the vehicle that's an indication
also that that uh trailer might be
overweight so
braking and steering are the two most
important things and obviously it could
certainly damage the vehicle to the
point where uh would blow a tire or
something like that as well so
um
a tire that's overloaded uh heats up
um as the heat increases in the tire the
pressure increases and if it increases
enough it will actually blow the tire so
there are a number of things that at
least three that i've just mentioned
that are part of the safety aspect of
that
i've got one if you don't mind we'll get
to in a minute
just for clarification getting back to
that f-150 with the two pallets of
shingles um
you said that it was probable cause if
you noticed it going down the street
with the rear bumper dragging but if you
were to pull them over for that overload
situation or suspected
would you make them drive five ten miles
to the nearest scales to actually get
weighed no we would um and i've done
this before myself so i can speak to
this we would get them
either to a wide part of the road or to
a driveway somewhere to to take a look
at the vehicle
the
the 10 mile portion of this
mainly is for commercial vehicles
most of our troopers now that do truck
enforcement we carry portable scales
with us so we're typically not dry
having somebody drive that
that far that's a valid point
moving something that you suspect is
significantly overweight even further um
that is a valid point and we would try
to get the vehicle again even on the
shoulder wide shoulder of the road to
determine whether or not it's actually
overweight
thank you representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman thank you taking
my question um
is there another citation you could pull
them over for to give them this
education and then penalize them for if
they do not learn from the education
rather than forcing them to go to a
yes and no
specifically
no as far as weight goes
there's a statute for
the weight statutes in 266 18 address
cross vehicle weight
mainly for larger trucks but also talks
about
tire capacity
however you would still need to weigh
the vehicle to determine if the vehicle
was beyond the tire capacity of the
vehicle
um but again this is something that we
don't do very often as i said before i
think it's been a half a dozen times in
the last
five years
and
again
we're able to stop a commercial vehicle
without probable cause
we would only stop a non-commercial or a
privately owned vehicle
if we
had probable cause to believe that the
vehicle was overweight or there was a
further questions from the committee
representative gorski
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um it's kind of
doug-tailing what the chairman asked
about the shingles and the f-150 and you
mentioned pulling the car over
if you kind of have a conversation with
the driver and you mentioned sometimes
it's an educational issue yes
if you're pulling them off to the side
and you've determined this is overloaded
what happens at that point do you
like have the drive behind the person to
get their destination or does the car
have to sit there what kind of happens
afterwards so uh great question thank
you um a lot of times we'll try to
get the the driver or the owner to make
an arrangement to have somebody else
come over with another truck to offload
it a little bit
or
if
they're in a
place where
there happens to be a
either a town or a state owned facility
they could unload part of the load there
but yes um even on the commercial side
of things um we would
make them unload
um to get to the point where it was safe
to drive again but
a lot of times
people have to unload a portion of what
they're carrying
thank you
representative talerski
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you brought up the
issue of a trailer and overloaded
trailer and i'm curious if this
clarification was made in the statute if
it would prevent you from addressing a
vehicle that's pulling what appears to
be an overloaded trailer
my
my understanding of this would be to
eliminate our ability to stop anything
that wasn't a commercial vehicle any
anyone else
representative
oh that's right rambo i'm sorry
all right
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so you clarified that
the commercial vehicles do not need
probable cause correct but for the
non-commercial vehicles to do so in
those
six instances or so in the last five
years that you're recalling
the officer had to make the
determination you know probable cause it
was over 20 overloaded correct yes so
that framework is always in place for
the non-commercial yes
this is um
we would not do this randomly uh
any if many of you have probably gone by
either the windham scales are gone by
the canterbury rest area or we've got
the signs out to say all trucks uh enter
um
that's how we screen uh commercial
vehicles for
other violations other than weight but
that's typically
we watch a vehicle come in we run them
over a set of scales and determine
whether or not they're overweight
we typically do not do that with
passenger vehicles um
again this is something that doesn't
happen very often however we we have to
have probable cause to to stop the
non-commercial vehicle and
based on you know a trooper or an
officer's
knowledge and experience they would make
a call and say hey that looks like it's
overloaded um we would then stop it and
any other questions representative sykes
thank you mr chairman thank you sergeant
um
could you just help me out a little bit
about this probable cause business
it's unclear to me whether
it is a policy of the department to not
stop
private vehicles unless you have
probable cause or whether it is a
an rsa or something like that or a rule
that differentiates for probable cause
reasons for commercial and private
vehicles
okay um
so
is
i'll talk about commercial for just a
second commercial vehicles
we don't need probable cost to stop them
as long as
the officer trooper is certified we're
certified by the federal murder carious
administration to do
commercial vehicle inspections
our administrative rules and law
allow us to stop
a commercial vehicle or one that appears
to be in commerce without probable cause
to do an inspection we
look at
the vehicle the load the driver
qualifications and things like that
that's the commercial side
in order for us to stop a vehicle any
vehicle whether it be for speed an
inspection sticker or anything like that
we need reasonable suspicion to believe
either a crime has committed or there is
a violation of state law so it's more
than just a hey i want to stop a car it
would be
a that vehicle looks like it potentially
is overweight or unsafe that's the
determined that would be our reasonable
reasonable suspicion or probable cause
to believe that the vehicle is
overweight
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
i have nobody else signed up to speak on
this if there's anybody else that wishes
to
now's the time
seeing that i'm going to close the
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee i remain representative
stephen smith sullivan county district
act where charlestown goes from land to
if you've been
i always do it alphabetical i don't like
to show favoritism if um if you've been
on the committee for a while you'll
recall when we had the brutal fight to
get the new version of the hands-free
law passed
and the reason that we did that was
because the old one was not working
we had a previous distracted driving law
and we never know what happens once we
pass the law how it's going to be
implemented
hey look at that
thanks
gonna make me lose my groove
anyway thank you
so what we've we found afterwards was
yeah you can't drive while you're
distracted and as i mentioned earlier
the miles that i drive you see some
things i've seen people with newspapers
spread out across their steering wheel
clearly distracted right okay can you
get cited for that absolutely are you
gonna get convicted no because here's
what was happening the court was
applying a subsequent act standard
so you can be distracted and clearly so
um
have that newspaper out but until you
hit me
you weren't distracted that's how they
were proving distraction you do
something wrong so if you're managing to
stay in your lane while you're doing
that
up until the very moment that you wreck
me and kill my family you're not
distracted
so that's why we passed the new version
unfortunately what got by us when we did
that was we didn't repeal the old one
we have a new better one
this is the old one it's a straight up
repeal the new one's working we don't
need this and that's why the bill was
put in
that's all i have mr chair thank you
representative talarsky
thank you thank you representative smith
um i'm noticing a line that is the
commercial motor vehicle
section
um line three
is that also simply repealing the
distracted driving line for commercial
drivers
yeah supposed to reference the new
statute oh referencing the new statute
correct okay thank you i just want to
sorry can i do a follow-up absolutely as
we don't so line three redirects to
26579 we don't need to do anything once
we repeal the other one because two six
five seven nine's already in place
just
where it needs to be that's the intent i
don't know the statute sitting in front
of me but that is all the bills supposed
to do okay
well i'm sure we'll double check it
before we yes please thank you
[Laughter]
seeing none thank you and we'll take
oh
i knew if held out long enough i'd get
one
oh it's a different one
steve is ahead of the game
anyone else wished to speak on
house bill 1562
seeing none i'll close the hearing on
1562.
okay
session on
first up is representative
walsh
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is tom
walsh
representative from the town of hooksett
and i'm here to introduce
my last bill before transportation and
hopefully the simplest one we have this
year
uh it's 1534 authorizing the site uh use
of side exhaust for antique vehicles
side exhausts
you may be you may remember them from
the 60s and 70s
corvettes came with them from the
factory side pipes
uh in those same model years 50s 60s and
70s a lot of people used to run these
their tail pipes just out of the vehicle
before the rear wheel which is no longer
legal
for many different reasons usually it's
because there's no room behind the rear
wheels to run your custom dual exhaust
whether it's the tub for the spare tire
or the fuel tank
and so if you want to run these exhausts
um you have to hang them down two three
inches and they're absolutely awful this
has been a pet peeve of mine for a while
uh if you can have them legally on some
vehicles why can't you have them on
other vehicles these it's going to be a
very limited number we're looking at the
antiques what i had ols do was just look
at the
custom vehicle statute and the hot rod
statute and match it
so and they're allowed in those vehicles
as well
i will admit
i did get a recommendation from the
department of motor vehicles to make one
change by amendment
if you look at re uh line five
it says
discharge point to the rear edge i mean
to the rear of the rear edge of the
front door
and such system shall direct exhaust gas
away from the vehicle i am going to get
an amendment for it uh to the rear edge
of the rear most door or something along
those lines
just in case somebody with a four door
opts to run this type of exhaust and i
don't
foresee much of that but i'll make the
change i don't see an issue
again this isn't just for vanity uh it's
because in some of these old a-bodies
and g-bodies there's just no other way
to do it
and people still like customizing their
vehicles doesn't change anything for
decibels or mufflers or anything else
that's required it's just a discharge
point
that's pretty much all this bill does
again hopefully it's the most the
simplest bill we have we'll see if
anybody behind me contradicts that
thank you mr chair
representative rambo
thank you mr thank you for taking my
question and this again maybe a newbie
question when you refer to the custom uh
language you clarified with the hot rod
and the custom vehicles when it says
antique in here is that used when it
says antique in the bill that uses a
term of art that would reference back
to
a certain framework of what constitutes
an antique vehicle yeah i don't have the
statute while the statute 266
you'd have to look if you if you look
into our statutes in the 266
there's three separations you've got the
antique vehicle by definition hot rods
by definition and
custom vehicles so in those bottom two
it's already legal to do this i just
want to
include it in the antique vehicles as
well okay thank you for clarifying that
and lastly on that i i see it as a very
small amount of vehicles because quite
honestly the newer vehicles beyond that
there's just no reason for people to do
it on front-wheel drive vehicles that
it's a style thing for those types of
cars
any other questions from yes
representative manji booty
thank you mr chair
i'm substituting for
my colleague here um justin a question
about carbon monoxide building is the
exhaust being
beyond the back door
that would help from not having any
going to the rare yeah that was the
concern of the department
and it's an oversight i guess most of
the custom vehicles and hot rods don't
have four doors but obviously some
antiques do so if we just change the
language to make sure the pipe is beyond
basically the the interior compartment
it relieves their concerns
thank you
anyone else
representative fenton
thank you for taking my question um i'm
a hot rod enthusiast as well
my question was just to make sure it
adheres to that of the other law you're
speaking about um
side exhaust can get quite loud is there
a decibel level that
needs to maintain or does antique
vehicles perhaps not
need to adhere to that decimal level no
they nothing is going to change the
decibel level now i don't have that in
front of me but there's no intention of
this to change anything for sound
they're still going to be required to
have the mufflers that they are now
you know catalytic converters etc etc it
merely is just a discharge point
and again for the main reason i've got
for example a 79 malibu
um
in any of those styles if you wanted to
run dual exhaust
there's no place to put them out back
and the only place it really fits
without seeing it is before the front
wheels not to mention it's also cool but
besides
yeah
it's nice to split up the sound of eight
cylinders
anyone
else seeing none thank you
next up
can you hear me now okay uh i
representative walsh actually took my
talking point so i was just going to add
that the state police would be in
support
of the bill with that added language of
just the rear part of the rear most
passenger door that was all
thank you any questions
[Laughter]
anyone else wishing to testify who
didn't fill out a card
seeing none
i will close
the hearing on
being 11 10 we're going to open up the
public hearing on house bill 1447
prohibiting state agencies from using
face recognition technology
chair recognizes representative mcguire
good morning mr chair members of the
committee i'm carol mcguire representing
merrimack district 29 which is
allenstown epsilon pittsfield
house bill 1447
is
about half of a bill that passed the
house i think three times already
it
it deals
bans the use of face recognition
technology
by
state agencies it does not address the
issue of
what's allowable in courts or
for presenting evidence
because
there were at least three groups of
lawyers who had different strongly
different positions on that and that has
killed
other
face recognition bills that we've had in
the past
this simply says that the driver's
license database which contains a
picture of
a good portion of the people of new
hampshire
shall not be used for face recognition
and it also means that the
other agencies shall not create or
maintain a searchable database of faces
they can still create and use
the facial databases that they have now
where they for example type in the name
and say yes this here's a picture of
warren davis i'm looking at this person
and he's the one that is authorized to
come pick up a child at this visitation
center or here's a picture of
john williams he's
he is in fact a state employee and he's
authorized to enter this building
something like that is not a problem
uh what we don't want is to have the
agencies receiving pictures of people
and then
trying to compare them to their database
that's open to
a lot of false positives particularly
for
the elderly
women and non-whites
so it's somewhat discriminatory
and it also is a
of one's privacy
you might be interested to know that the
irs
just this
just this morning i saw on the wall
street journal they are no longer going
to be using face of recognition
to establish one's identity because it's
too easy to game and it's
again difficult to
and it's discriminatory in which faces
it recognizes it's really good at you
know 30 year old technologists in
silicon valley but it's not so good in
new hampshire
facial recognition and this merely
protects the state
photo databases
from that use and i'll answer any
questions i can
thank you representative if any
was it representative hill
oh representative thompson i'm sorry
i do have one um how about easy pass
where where are you with that
that's an excellent question i don't
know don't know that they had one is
that's not a state agency so it
it wouldn't be affected by the bill
so
are you implying that easy pass
scans not only your your driver's
i believe that is the case and and i
believe um
because ezpass is multi-state
i don't know whether that would be
shared
within that
that
product
that's
that would not be affected by the bill
as i read it
also it encourages
i want to encourage everyone everyone to
wear dark glasses and a hat while you're
going through the tolls
that'll confuse a fake a
don't forget the groucho marx glasses
representative thompson
as i read the
lines 9 10 and 11
it says that uh
you may not use
viewing of a represent
representation of an individual on a
computer video recording
photograph or other media
if we're not supposed to use a
photograph to identify people sir that's
the exemption
it says
that face recognition technology does
not include using a photograph to
okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
excuse me my committee's meeting so i
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question so
i just looked at 263 40-b and it's
pretty straightforward the department is
prohibited from using
any facial recognition technology in
connection with taking or retaining
any photograph or digital image for
purposes of this chapter
stop full stop
i'm not quite sure what what you're
trying to accomplish it's already
thank you thank you represent
representative for finding that out i
may not have done my my research as
thorough as i should have if that is in
fact the case then that covers my
concerns
i do want to i did want to ban other
agencies from using facial recognition
so if if it needs to be trimmed to just
the line the sentence starting on page
five about
the state agency other state agencies
shall not do so i would be perfectly
any other questions
next up chair recognizes elizabeth
sargent
representing new hampshire association
of chiefs of police in opposition of the
bill
good morning chairman walsh members of
the committee my name is beth sargent
i'm here i work for championing capital
group here in concord and i'm here to
testify in opposition to the bill on
behalf of the new hampshire association
of chiefs of police
i've handed chief professors testimony
around the table and i won't read it but
i'll just
make a couple of statements from it the
chiefs are concerned this would prohibit
the state of new hampshire from using
technology that would be helpful in
solving crimes crimes with victims and a
cost to society
in a state of limited resources which
includes law enforcement the ban on the
use of this technology further inhibits
new hampshire law enforcement from being
able to help solve serious crimes that
have real victims in an efficient
effective and most importantly a timely
manner
it is important to recognize new
hampshire law enforcement expects to use
this technology only under close
judicial scrutiny and would not use
these tools as a sole and only mechanism
to charge subjects with a crime
um
and i guess i'll wrap it up there and in
conclusion the chiefs respectfully ask
that you find this bill and expedient to
legislate
thank you any questions from the
committee
next up the chair recognize henry value
representing security industry
uh thank you mr chairman uh and members
of the committee for the record my name
is henry dayu
and i'm here on behalf of the
security industry association which is a
trade organization
comprised of businesses
that provide um
security products and services to
multitude of
governments and businesses around the
country including businesses here in new
hampshire
i've
passed around
some written testimony also emailed it
to the committee because there are some
links
in some of the footnotes that might
provide some information that i thought
you could just click on
so i provided it electronically too
[Music]
so we have concerns with
the bill it basically just bans
the outright use of
facial recognition technology
there are
valuable uses
of the technology i mean with any
technology
there are uh valuable uses but if used
wrong
um
you know some bad it's bad but um
there are valuable uses of this
technology
um
and the industry actually has put
together a bunch of principles
that should guide the use of this
technology including transparency
it should be transparent
uh when this technology is used
uh data privacy
um
human oversight
uh
so in looking at the use of technology
we think that it's more advisable to
look at ways to maybe
put
bounds around it rather than to ban it
all together
it is often used uh with human
trafficking
um
especially with children
it is uh used in a number of uh crime
uh investigations
and typically
the use of facial recognition technology
and
the results of it are not
the sole thing
that is brought to a court
for a conviction
it typically is used as a lead
to say here's a match here
let's go get some more evidence and find
out if this is the individual that we're
looking for
um
that has been done that that's been
that that process has been used by law
enforcement even before the technology
except it's been a hand process it's
been a much slower process and trying to
match photos
this basically just speeds it up
is what it does
uh but again it is
not used as the sole thing that can
convict someone it's it's used as a tool
oftentimes just hedging the right
direction there have been some other
states
that have banned the use of it and have
reversed it because
they realized there were some
applications
where it was useful
and so we would just caution this
committee
to
move slowly
in this direction
uh maybe sending the bill to interim
study
on behalf of the industry i'd be happy
at some point later this session or the
interim study period to get uh officials
and uh people in the organization and
with the companies to come come in and
explain a little more in its use
but we just feel throwing it out all
together
uh is not a wise thing to do because
there are a lot of benefits that this
stuff can bring
again put some boundaries around it
that's that's probably worthwhile set
some policy
principles in the statute maybe that
could provide guidance on its use uh but
all together banning uh just doesn't
seem the right thing to do and i'd be
happy to take any questions
thank you representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um do you have those
policies written down somewhere by any
chance i do and actually it's one of the
hyperlinks in the uh
in the uh
letter that i emailed you uh it's one of
the it's the first footnote and those
representative hill thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
as i understand it this isn't an
outright ban this is only suggesting
that um the technology be used within
a single department not shared amongst
departments
um
is that not your understanding as well
and and would that be an issue for your
association what makes it problematic if
you look at the first sentence of the
bill
it says the department shall not allow
access to any of its digital
representations
of faces by any face recognition
technology nor shall the department use
face recognition technology so for
law enforcement outside of the state
that wants outside of
the local law enforcement wanting to
match up a face with um
a
digital representation of a face
that the state has
would be prohibited by this and that's
that's the large database that law
enforcement use
uh to try to match up a face that
actually has the information about a
person that could provide a lead so
that's where it becomes problematic it
sort of indirectly
shuts it all down
any other questions representative
manjuputi
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
the surveillance uh cameras
in private sector or in say the corner
grocery store and stuff
that data is used as an initial
screening correct with the local lion
enforcement if there's a break break in
or something so that's more of
facial recognition in the video would
that
be
banned if this goes through
so the video that you would
have running in a grocery store
department store whatever
is a little different than the term
facial recognition technology that is
actually matching up uh people maybe an
image
from
that video would be used with the
technology to try to match up a person
so um
that's sort of the difference between
what you're describing
in the technology that again i mean
before the technology you would have
someone in law enforcement look at that
video and then try to somehow match it
up with which
would take a long time so again this
kind of speeds up the process
um
yup follow-up yeah thank you so in the
past when this technology was not
available
and my understanding is that they would
have a sketch somebody artists catch the
image and then witness would match up
with the sketch of if there was a
witness am i correct so there i think
are some law enforcement people here
from the state that can probably
get into that a little uh better than i
can
i'm not as familiar with their
techniques
further questions
representative
so i think part of the motive behind
this is to
reduce mistaken identity
uh that it was suggested that
the software might
misidentify somebody and cause them you
know the person to be accosted for no
reason
is is that
is it better to have a person personally
looking at it and and trying to identify
it would would that reduce
is is a person's eye more accurate than
the technology would that reduce
mistaken identities and
the problem of arresting somebody who
may not be the right person
and representative let me just say in
the 35 years that i've been lobbying up
here you're the first representative of
you that i've actually run into
so
very nice to meet you hello i think the
first i was going to ask you how do you
um that's a yeah that's a fair question
exactly i mean um
there's going to be uh is any uh a
process perfect no
i do know that the technology
has gotten a lot better than it used to
be when it first came out
there was maybe a 89
success rate
but it's improved dramatically
and
it's getting better
representative thompson
as i understand this bill this would
prevent motor vehicle
who has the largest database of
faces in the state
but it wouldn't prevent local law
enforcement from creating a network
which i'm sure your company or one of
them could produce that would take all
of the images
that the local police have
captured in their systems
in
with people that are suspected of crimes
or actual criminals and sharing that
information amongst themselves
just without the use of the database
is that your understanding as well yes
exactly
thank you
further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
next up
frank nack from the aclu of new
uh mr chairman members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify today my name is frank knack i'm
the policy director with the aclu of new
hampshire and we are here in strong
support of hb 1447.
um i think this is one of those unusual
bills where it
like we can look at it from two
perspectives if the technology works is
one perspective to look at it but then
also looking at it from the reality that
this technology has a severe error rate
and so study after study have revealed
that their serious flaws with racial uh
facial recognition technology
mit back in 2018 did a study that found
that one in three times it misclassified
black women so over 33 percent
of the time it misclassified black women
more recently the national institute of
standards and technology did a massive
review and found that the algorith
algorithms false matched black women
between 10 and 100 times more often than
white men
and between 2 and 10 times more often
between white women and white men so
this technology works fairly well if
you're a middle-aged white person
outside of that category it does not
work has a fairly severe error rates
in addition the aclu
looked at we took all the members of
congress of federal congress
and ran them to the technology system it
false matched 28 members of congress as
someone who had committed a crime and
then again the error rate was there was
a staggering disparity between white
members of congress and black members of
congress at the time black members of
congress comprised about 20 percent of
the house and 39 of those where there
was an error rate
so that's and then also this technology
these tests were done with good mugshot
photos in reality we all know that the
way these photos are going to be
compiled are not going to be good you
know passport style photos are going to
be grainy photos from surveillance
cameras etc so again these horrible
error rates are then going to be
magnified when this technology is used
in the real world
and then
i'd like to talk a little bit about the
real world harms of this technology you
know this is not an abstract
conversation about how this analogy may
or may not work in theory in practice
at least three times black men have been
falsely arrested and we don't know more
than that because there's no
transparency around this so we don't
know how many times other people have
been falsely arrested
so we do know three times just from some
good reporting
one of those men was robert williams in
detroit
he was arrested based on a false match
in his lawn in front of his wife and two
children
and he said i want to quote this how
does one explain to two young girls that
a computer got it wrong but the police
listened anyway
so this is the technology that we're
talking about bringing into new
hampshire it should be concerning to all
of us
and then let's look at it even if all
those factors those errors that i just
mentioned weren't true that this
technology actually worked this
technology is again something we should
not even consider bringing into new
hampshire this is the dystopian
nightmare this is the thing where
basically it's equivalent of having your
driver's license blown up put on your
person with a geo-locator and then
sending you out into the communities
that's how severe this technology is
this technology is certainly it's
currently being used in china for
example to completely map
certain populations how many times they
pray
where they enter their homes who their
social contacts are that should be
something that is extremely concerning
to us in a country where we value civil
liberties and civil rights where we
should be able to go to protest go to
you know uh health care providers
substance use treatment programs without
fear that all that information is in
going into a database that can then be
searched
and again six states including new
hampshire have already put limits in
certain cases on use of technology so in
our body cam law that we passed a few
years back there's a provision that
limits the use of facial
racial technician technology and use of
body cam footage and then 21 at least 21
local governments have also
banned the use of facial recognition
technology across the country including
a number of our neighboring localities
in massachusetts and maine and then
vermont has done a ban so we think this
is the right move for new hampshire we
think this technology is problematic in
its application and then even if it
worked it's not something we should
consider bringing into our state so
thank you for your time
thank you any questions from the
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um is this something
that
maybe
uh could be used in a limited basis like
a fingerprint file where the computer
identifies a few possibilities and then
a human comes in after and
and verifies the information
is that
something that
could be considered i think from our
perspective we'd have even concerns with
that one because of the way it's
actually working in practice right now
with its severe error rate
particularly for non-middle-aged white
people and then two the impact that this
could have on the basic freedoms that we
enjoy
it's just this is a total surveillance
tool something that we have never seen
before you know think of automatic
license plate readers which have you
know severe concerns it enables you to
get around constitutional
rights protections in terms of the way
they're geofenced but it's not the total
invasive tool that this technology would
bring and even with alpr's we put limits
on those it's really restricted the use
of that so this is alpr's much much
worse
any further questions from the committee
um i saw representative o'hara first
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um i do agree with
you on the privacy aspect of the bill
um i just had a question if you because
i almost set the standard that about the
statistics part
sorry any
studies done
to show the accuracy difference between
the facial recognition and someone's
eyes
i've actually i don't know the answer to
that i can definitely look into that and
get back to you though
what are the questions
represented major potential
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
i'm just
curious to find out
how does this compare with
inherent bias racial bias of human
beings
you know it does identify and this is
digital you know to recognize
it's you know it's a tool
a tool is as good as uh the person who
creates the tool right so
is there
any uh thought put into
finding which the racial bias inherent
bias
versus digital bias because it was
developed that way yeah so in terms of
the like how the algorithm was created
itself um i'm not a technologist so i
couldn't get into the weeds of how the
algorithms were created um i do know
that that is a flag that has been raised
by others in this context and i think
it's also important to realize too that
you know the way this technology will
then be deployed on communities that
have been historically over policed and
under-resourced and so even in a state
like new hampshire you know marijuana is
a great example white people and black
people use marijuana at roughly the same
rate national studies have long shown
that in new hampshire black people are
almost five times more likely to be
arrested for marijuana possession and so
we already know that policing is done in
a way that disproportionately harms
certain communities and so then when you
add in new technologies like this that
have inherent flaws in them that are
also going to disproportionately harm
black and brown community members you
further questions representative
talerski
i guess it's representative crawford
thank you very much
so you mentioned vermont and i was just
reading uh the previous gentleman's
[Music]
statement that in vermont after a
sweeping ban on law enforcement's use
for past was passed in 2020 policymakers
discovered that the ban
exten extended even to software for
analyzing seized digital
evidence and child
sexual exploitation cases then they
they the legislature returned in 2021 to
pass a bill exempting such software
do you agree with that
um i would have to look into that
specific angle and i also know in
vermont there's exceptions for search
and rescue as well so
these are not the state bands are not
total bands they are
kind of limited to certain scopes
so we think new hampshire could be
leading away in this respect
virginia for example just passed the
total moratorium on use thank you
further questions representative
telersky you still have one
okay
representative
sorry um can i just have your um
thoughts we we pointed out to the
sponsor that the existing statute of
rsa 263
colon 40b
already prohibits
the use of facial recognition technology
yes i noted that when um the
representative noted that earlier and
i'm going to research that as soon as i
get back i had not seen that before so
then i will hold up thank you i had only
seen in the context of bodywork cameras
where there's
a carve out
okay thank you
uh thank you just one question for me
does the federal government or any of
the federal law uh enforcement agencies
use this technology
um i believe the answer is yes and
there's a there's an effort underway to
have a federal moratorium but i don't
have all the specifics on the federal
level so thank you
anybody else
um
next up chair recognizes captain joseph
ebert new hampshire state police in
hi good morning everyone my name is joe
ebert it's e-b-e-r-t i'm a captain with
the state police i oversee our
investigative services bureau which is
our detective bureau
so i want to start by saying i've
testified on facial recognition on uh
several years
in the past and this has been a
tremendous conversation i think a lot of
the points that typically have
cumulatively come up over the past uh
have been discussed this morning
so i was hoping to address uh we are in
opposition to the to the bill one of the
uh if i could direct your attention to
line four and five
in particular where it says nor shall
the department use face recognition
technology
this may be an unintended consequence of
the way that the bill was written but
the way that we read that is that we
would be as a state entity be prohibited
from using facial recognition technology
that is otherwise legal in another
jurisdiction
there were some questions earlier about
uh what jurisdictions i uh mr chairman i
think you would ask does the federal
government the federal government does
allow for facial recognition technology
we often work joint cases with the
department of state
and they have a facial recognition
technology system
we also work with other out-of-state
agencies state police agencies mostly
that have utilization of facial
recognition recognition systems
so i want to
i think an
unintended consequence of this uh bill
may be
creating a vulnerability uh or
furthering a vulnerability for new
hampshire
we as i mentioned have in the past had
especially with our troopers out of
troop g which is our dmv uh bureau
will do an investigation and they may be
doing an investigation on an imposter
somebody who
they believe has fraudulently obtained a
license
they may work with an out-of-state
jurisdiction which they have done in the
past and identify that this individual
is in fact not who they claim to be
now there was some discussion
from one of the representatives about
the current prohibition that is on the
books as we understand the current
prohibition the the prohibition is of
using the facial
using
the images that are captured by dmv for
facial recognition so what we do is we
find an individual that
may present to us for any number of
reasons
but somebody who's brought to our
attention as an individual who may in
fact be creating uh or committing a
crime we then find an alternative image
for that individual not using the
department of motor vehicles uh image
one of the prior
speakers had said to you that uh one of
the concerns they had was the uh
the poor format or the uh the uh the the
poor taking of this uh this image i i
would i would argue to you that that's
a good argument as to why you would use
the department of motor vehicles because
it is the very best image that you in
most instances that you can capture but
having said that
we we will find another image that has
been captured of this individual and
utilize that out of state technology or
that federal technology
i wanted to bring your attention to a
2009 case which happened to be a case
that
i was the lead investigator on
which is why i know it well
it dealt with
fraudulent
licenses that were being issued through
the department of vehicles here in new
hampshire
we worked with our out-of-state partners
on this particular case
and what we were able to find is that
there were numerous individuals who had
come to the state of new hampshire who
also had a license in neighboring states
what we also found in debriefing one of
the
primary individuals involved in this it
was a drug trafficking organization that
was facilitating the drug trafficking
via these fraudulent licenses
what we were also able to find as we
debriefed her she told us we
specifically targeted the state of new
hampshire because we knew you did not
have facial recognition technology so
she was telling us she was telegraphing
to us this is why we came to new
hampshire she also told us that when
those individuals
would come to they were often jump
points the jump points were
typically new york city or other large
cities
south of our border they would come to
new hampshire they would obtain a
license they would obtain
other housing assistants other food
assistants and other assistants that is
available
with good cause to those people within
the state who need it but they would do
that fraudulently and then they would
return to out of state
so uh what it pointed out to me or what
it highlighted to me is that uh we were
vulnerable in that regard
i think there was uh some good good
discussion both by the uh uh by the aclu
as well as
uh by the bill's sponsor about false
positives there was also some good
discussion uh somebody brought up a
fingerprint a partial fingerprint well
what happens with that partial
fingerprint is this partial fingerprint
what we take to a grand jury to indict
somebody
and i i think it's really important to
know that facial recognition technology
is as one of the representatives uh
referred to it as as a tool it is one
part of an investigation
uh in the past i've been asked well
do you arrest people based on
the facial
the facial recognition technology hit
itself and the answer to that is no uh
the aclu had referenced prior to uh me
speaking uh
some cases where people were arrested i
i'm i'm not familiar with them i will uh
take the time to to talk to the lobbyist
afterward because i am interested to see
were those cases where there was no
other investigation that was done that
they relied only on the
facial recognition hit
i think it's important if the state of
new hampshire is looking to put
guidelines around or guard rails to
around the use of facial recognition
technology then it should be discussed
that uh there are certain steps that
have to be taken that it cannot be only
uh the the
lice are the photo hit that is caused
for an arrest it shouldn't be there
should be other items
in the course of an investigation it
i also want to talk about uh eyewitness
uh eyewitness identification
so i found myself uh for a number of
different reasons to be before
committees to talk about uh
lineups and the fallibility of
eyewitness identification and we know
from research that eyewitness
identification can be fallible
we also know that
there are false positives and that
facial recognition technology can be
fallible but in the same way that we
address that with eyewitness
identification we use it as one piece to
a puzzle
and i've
it's my belief on behalf of the division
of state police if you start to take
away those pieces of the puzzle you can
never complete it
so if you say well eyewitness
identification is fallible and therefore
we shouldn't use it digital
we shouldn't use it you start to take
away the tools that are available to law
enforcement to be able to solve
these crimes that are impacting the
granite state
so with that um i i closed my testimony
but i am certainly willing to take any
questions that you may have
thank you very much
representative thompson
correct me if i'm wrong but
with the
the technology we have now on
fingerprinting um years ago used to hold
the two cards up and
try to figure out if you had the right
guy
but
they take points in the fingerprint
almost exactly the same the way facial
recognition is done it picks
points in that face
um and compares it to another face
or
another image that you have just like
fingerprint technology does
so
am i wrong at that is that
uh so representative thompson thank you
for the question i i think it's
important to say that um
i believe that is my understanding of uh
what takes place with the back end of uh
facial recognition technology i think it
should also be pointed out that it's my
uh understanding and i can't say this uh
definitively so i just put that out as a
qualifier but it's my understanding that
fingerprint technology is is more
accurate than facial recognition
technology
but the concept
of what you're talking about is still
the same it's a part it's a piece it's
one thing that is analyzed it is given
back to you as one part of an
investigation that you will then use to
branch out into another part of an
investigation to try and corroborate
that evidence
thank you very much representative
o'hara
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um can
can i safely assume you've never gone to
a judge for an arrest warrant with just
a facial recognition you can okay follow
up
thank you
um
in your in your opinion what would the
so it that uh representative o'hara
thank you uh for that question it's
that's certainly very uh it calls on a
lot of speculation on my part but in my
opinion a judge if you went to the judge
was simply just the uh the hit within a
facial recognition system i think it's
very likely the judge would not sign
that warrant but again i can't state
that as fact i can only surmise that
that would be the outcome of it but
that's my assumption when we write an
affidavit especially an affidavit for a
serious crime those are pages and pages
and pages for a homicide i
having worked in our major crime unit
for years uh a homicide affidavit is 60
70 80 pages long if not longer
though it's a listing of all the facts
in that case so i i feel very strongly
that if i went to a judge with an
affidavit that was one sentence long
that said this the system had turned out
a hit um that that that would likely not
be signed
further questions
thank you mr sayer for indulging me uh
thank you for taking my question a few
years ago this is my fifth term my
first and second term i've served on
criminal justice and public safety
during those times would you believe
that body cameras were just being
introduced and it was
new technology and it was not safe but
that has become a critical tool right
now so i understand this is maturing but
wouldn't this
be uh
like you said hindrance if you don't
have another tool in your toolbox
thank you representative
that is our stance our stance is that um
there are very few things that should be
taken
as solely the answer to any question
but taking away the tools that we have
to find that answer
makes our job
incredibly difficult and and i really
want to emphasize oftentimes when i sit
before a committee i i think um as a
member of law enforcement may come
across that well your your job is to
find somebody and and put arrest that
person hold them responsible
but i can't state strongly enough that's
the position of the division of state
police that that is our job but our job
is also to find the right person
and we have absolutely no desire to
incarcerate somebody nor take somebody's
freedoms away who has
not committed a crime so when i hear the
description of somebody who was arrested
solely based on this
um and it was it turned out to be
incorrect that that's horrible that's a
horrible situation that i would never
want to encounter which is again why i
say if the state is looking to
put guardrails in uh around the use of
facial recognition recognition
technology we're more than willing to
one more
sorry thank you so i asked this question
of the previous
presenter too um
the human bias racial bias inherent bias
versus the technology bias how would you
rate that how would you
[Music]
fix
sure uh so thank you uh for the the
question but
uh
i listened to that as i was uh sitting
in the back and i thought well that's a
really interesting point that i hadn't
um that i hadn't encountered before in
my testimony
you know
i don't know the answer to that but i
think it would be
it's certainly worth exploring uh if the
committee was so inclined to send this
to uh study it's it's certainly worth
a discussion as to
what is more uh fallible the bias in a
person or the software that facial
recognition uses and i don't know the
answer to that but i think it's an
representative
did you have your hand up yes
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question do you believe it's these
bill pass would uh
put victims of human trafficking in in
in like will hurt the investigation for
human trafficking is better than helping
representative perez thank you for the
question uh
i i think uh
to
hone it down to just one criminal
offense would be difficult what i think
i would feel comfortable saying is that
it would hinder the apprehension of
individuals who have committed multiple
crimes
throughout the state of new hampshire
meaning uh they may in fact we may be in
fact be working with a federal partner
um
homeland security investigations on a
on on a case as you had mentioned so it
may hinder
human trafficking in that regard if
we're working that type of case it may
also hinder a drug investigation if
we're working with dea it may also
hinder an investigation into an impostor
obtaining a license so to answer your
question it could
impact human trafficking uh although i
don't know that direct coalition
correlation what i would say is
in our opinion it's our feeling that it
could hinder all criminal investigations
thank you
representative gorski
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question you mentioned that
this has been a tool that's been used
for a number of years here in law
enforcement how many years has the new
hampshire law enforcement been used in
facial recognition software
that is a very good question sir and one
i can get you the answer i
i don't know the specific answer to that
what i can tell you is the case that i
referenced was in 2008 okay so i know
that at least as far back as 2008 uh we
were using outside entities uh uh in in
and i also want to make this very clear
what we're not doing is we're not trying
to usurp any law that is passed here in
the state of new hampshire by saying
okay well we know that
pick a state another state is uh has
lawful facial recognition technology
therefore we'll just take our case
investigation over there and ask them
for a favor that's not the case uh what
has happened though in the past is when
we are working jointly with an
out-of-state jurisdiction and there is
reason to go to that outer state
jurisdiction we have utilized their
technology but in terms of how long sir
i don't know the answer to that however
i'm more than happy to research it right
thank you
okay
i just ask everybody to look at the
clock not that these questions aren't
important
did you have your hand up representative
uh
what are your thoughts on i think one of
the fears is that
you know a crowd would be randomly
scanned at a protest or even a county
fair or something and every the list of
people who are in attendance is made
from their facial recognition hits is
that what do you
so i would not uh
i want to caution what i say is
with my own personal beliefs uh as
opposed to what the division of state
i i guess the uh the best way to phrase
that is
i i don't see that as being an invalid
concern
and if that was something a guardrail
that the state of new hampshire wanted
to put in place
that's certainly something that the
division of state police would be
willing to discuss
i don't think
it would not be our intent uh to be
scanning
large crowds of people
uh who were peacefully protesting uh not
committing any crime and then trying to
identify those individuals i can't
envision a time
uh devoid of a criminal undercurrent uh
that we would engage in that or that we
would be supportive of engaging in that
representative
thank you so much um i'm curious if you
believe um if you could clarify
that prohibits law enforcement from
currently
using dmv photographs is that correct
that is our understanding of that
statute okay quick follow-up
do you think that putting this
widespread prohibition of the technology
tacked onto a piece of motor vehicle law
is the proper and appropriate place to
put this prohibition or do you think
perhaps it needs to go somewhere else
so thank you very much representative
for the question i i won't pretend to
know the inner workings of how bills are
given uh amendments and whatnot i think
that's uh what what i can say is uh i'd
be uh i typically testify on this on the
other side of the hallway i'm not sure
how it ended up here but i'm happy to
testify in whatever committee the bill
appears before
seeing no other questions thank you very
much
uh final speaker on this um
ross connolly from afp new hampshire uh
i will try and not stand between you and
lunch uh my name is ross connolly i'm
the deputy state director for americans
for prosperity in new hampshire uh here
to voice our support for hb 14 47. uh as
has been discussed this is an emerging
technology that that uh
in the wrong hands could be used very uh
nefariously and dangerously and we
believe providing some some
uh guard rails within especially
government state government to ensure
that the the the technology is not being
abused and in the granite stater's
constitutional right to privacy is being
respected uh we do have a a
constitutional right to privacy here
article 2b
and uh we believe that this bill would
would be a good step to
backing that
constitutional amendment up
with some actual law and making sure
that that those bounds are not being
overstepped
our biggest concern
is really
government's using this technology in a
way that there there's no guard rails
and creating a panopticon of of constant
surveillance of individuals
uh that that could be used as as the the
representative from the aclu mentioned
in in very uh dystopian ways that that
has been implemented in other countries
other states do
uh use this technology in ways that we
do not but this legislation is proactive
instead of being reactive in its
approach to facial recognition
technology getting ahead of the problem
and making sure that
our government is not violat violating
these rights of granite staters
uh we think this would be an important
first step obviously there's a lot of
questions around how
the wording
i can't comment specifically on those
but i can say the way that we regard it
as is the only thing that's being
limited is the use of this statewide
database as has been pointed out a local
agency could still use this technology a
joint task force could still use this
technology with other jurisdictions uh
and we think that's appropriate that at
the state level we have a constitutional
right to privacy
that this database should not be
shared across government and using these
these neural net
platforms uh
with that uh just out of respect for the
committee's time i'll i'd be happy to
answer any questions if there are any
thank you sir many questions from the
committee representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
i have to account uh just say i feel
like this should be like the last step
when it comes to facial recognition this
is a complete ban um would you be
willing to help work with the committee
aclu and state police on
getting
guardrails in place because i do think i
understand the liberty and safety and
privacy i do think we need to get
guardrails in place there
but i just think we need this is like a
last option
thank you for the question
representative
yes and just just to provide some some
background we would be happy to help uh
in a process if you were looking to
amend the bill uh last year this a
similar bill went through the criminal
justice committee uh it was a little
more complicated in restricting the use
requiring warrants and and i believe the
sponsor wanted to avoid some of those
those complications that arose of when
you can get a warrant when you can't uh
and and uh some of the the more
nitty-gritty parts of how this is
implemented uh
we believe she she made it simpler to to
try and uh have people understand it's a
confusing topic
facial recognition and
so we'd be happy to work with with the
committee i i will point out we we do
believe that this is a technology that
can be valuable and identifying suspects
uh someone mentioned human trafficking
earlier it is used uh for for to track
down human traffickers victims of human
trafficking uh so it is a a useful
technology it just there needs to be
some sort of guardrail so that uh rights
aren't being violated
any further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much thank
you for your time uh that was the last
person i had signed up to speak is there
anybody else that wishes to
seeing none i'll close the public
yep
okay welcome back everybody i mean 104.
i'm going to open up the public hearing
on house bill 1474.
relative to annual vehicle inspections
chair recognizes the prime sponsor
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for hearing me i am as always
representative steven smith sullivan
county district 11. thanks for doing
these all in one day i appreciate it
so uh this bill
is to separate the two financial events
in somebody's life where they have to
pay a hundred couple hundred bucks to
get their car registered
and then almost immediately find out it
needs another few hundred bucks worth of
work to get past an inspection
you've heard a lot of inspection bills
and the safety argument is always the
vehicle should be seen once a year and i
agree with that we have seen enough
busted parts come in from inspections
and i know
that in the last few months i haven't
pulled my wheels and checked my brakes i
didn't check my wheel bearings i don't
know if there's any
up and down play in my ball joints that
happens when it gets inspected that's
just what happens i was a mechanic for
20 years i don't do it and i'd be
willing to bet that very few people in
this room have done that recently
so yes one year is the number
this bill accomplishes that right now if
you buy a car that has this is february
and it has a good november sticker on it
well it's not a year because you're
going to register it and then you're
going to have to get it inspected again
why if the argument is see the car every
year see the car every year
so what the bill accomplishes is that if
you buy one that has that good november
sticker you don't have to get it
inspected again until next november a
year
if you would like to get it inspected
sooner you can the person has control
if the person wants to always get the
car inspected in their birth month so
that they do the registration and
inspection at the same time they have
the freedom to do that
for me who drives
so much that i don't have a new vehicle
with a warranty because i'd chew it up
in two years
uh my car is a 99 volvo at the moment
i would like to separate the events i
don't know my birthday's in june i'd
like to get it done in april so that i
can make a decision about whether or not
to keep the car
mechanically it will probably be fine
because i do my own work but then
there's those pesky codes on newer
vehicles and if i get one of those well
i could get the 60-day sticker and still
drive the car while i'm making a
decision about buying another one or
chasing codes and sensors to get it
fixed
any event the car still gets seen at
least once a year
but i now have control over the
so that's pretty much what the first
section occurs
uh it accomplishes
it also gets rid of the
the weird problem that we have in the
law now where you can get a 16-month
inspection
you can also get a 16-month registration
but the way the statute's written you
can fall in the middle where you're
still going to be a year off on those
two what happened to my wife
we bought a car that had roughly 15 and
a half months to go
and we had to get an inspection for four
months later but we got a registration
for the next year
talk about confusing and annoying
this does not affect vehicles owned by
companies or corporations that's the
last paragraph
if a vehicle is the the owner is a
company or corporation other than a
natural person hate that term but there
it is the annual inspection shall be
made during the month designated by the
director as the registration month for
such a legal entity
the only other change is language to
have the new methods still apply to
antique vehicles
motorcycles recreational vehicles so
that they still get done in april in the
case of antique vehicles or july
i think that's
motorcycles and rvs
if you don't have a lot of money and
you're driving that 10 or 20 year old
car you're probably not doing it because
you like it you're doing it because
that's your economic reality
to spend a couple hundred bucks to
register it and find out within the next
10 days i just made a horrible mistake
because now this thing needs five or six
hundred dollars worth of work
800 000
all of a sudden on a low-income family
that means they don't have a car that's
what that means or they're going to try
driving it without the inspection that's
worse
so let's give those people some control
over these events let them get their car
inspected whenever they want as long as
it isn't longer than a year from now and
manage their own affairs
i've heard that this will be confusing
it'll cause chaos if the numbers don't
match people won't know
when to get their cars inspected stop it
people are smarter than that but how do
you know when to get your car inspected
easy if you've chosen to separate it
from your birth month which is the only
way it will be different because right
now it matches the person will have to
make a conscious
effort to change that date
when you walk up to your car from the
nose there's this really colorful
sticker about this big with a number on
it that's when you get inspected and
besides that we know that chaos won't
ensue because when i first started
coming up here in the 80s it didn't
match your birth month
every year
every vehicle
didn't match for half of the year
because inspections are six months so
and everything was okay then
so i'm asking the committee to do this
to let people take control of their
lives maybe make smarter decisions about
whether to fix or keep a vehicle
and give them back that power thank you
mr chair
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative
it says
if your
sticker expires within the next four
months you need to have a letter saying
you'll be out of town during your
inspection month can i choose to have my
car inspected any time as long as it's
before that one year or does it have to
be just within that four months if i'm
the um
so okay the four-month thing for when
you're out of town that's actually the
existing law
uh the only change to it is to make the
reference to owner's birth month occurs
but no like if you're always gone every
summer or whatever at a certain time and
you choose not to deal with that then
yeah just get your car inspected and
whatever month works for you
representative crawford
thank you representative um
do the inspection stickers and your
registration tags match
like if if i'm in to be inspected in
january and i um registered my car
obviously in january because that's what
it needed will that be confusing at all
for police or whoever looking at both
stickers
i don't know
i don't know those
stickers on the plates are pretty small
and considering where i live this time
of year you can't read my front plate
um i i think the big inspection sticker
in the windshield that they can see is
what they would taking on if you you're
any other questions representative hill
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um did i understand that it's not going
to affect or would it affect
um corporations all all are at one time
of the year and i think all
leases are at one time of the year i may
be wrong about that
that's not affected by this legislation
is that correct that's correct the only
change to that paragraph
uh which is the last one section three
in the bill
um
the previous language was without regard
to the owner's birth date
or registration month
referencing when the director says those
entities should register
it just changes the language to uh
strike that since it would no longer
apply but there's still whatever the
director says that's when you do it
thank you
wow seeing none thank you very much
the chair recognizes car carl huddleston
from new hampshire state police
department of safety and opposition to
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee thank you for hearing
my testimony
um
the department of safety stands in
opposition to this and
people now have been
ingrained in
when i register my car
i have to get it inspected a lot of
times when you re-register your car
whether it be at a dmv substation or at
one of the town clerks that can do the
whole thing for you they often remind
people that you need to get the vehicle
when we talk about enforcement roadside
or traveling down the road it will be
more confusing for any police officer to
differentiate between the sticker that's
on the plate and the sticker that's on
the windshield
yes i know those um little month
stickers
for some people are hard to read but um
that that's ingrained in our minds when
we first start in law enforcement that
the little
month sticker is supposed to match the
inspection sticker on the windshield
we have had
the state owned vehicles run differently
the registration month is march
and the inspection is in september new
hampshire d.o.t went to that
a couple years ago
it took law enforcement quite a while
just to recognize that it was different
and the reason why
so
i i think
it would
if this were to pass it would lend a lot
of confusion
not only to
and it coinciding with the registration
i think is probably the the biggest
benefit to the way the system is now
and as
it was just previously said you can get
an early inspection as well
under the current system that we have
representative talersky
thank you thanks for taking my question
can you just clarify what exactly what
you just said in terms of an earlier
inspection how many months in advance of
your posted
month can you go to get your inspection
four
four months so you can do a 16-month
sticker
okay let's
out
so potentially if someone was concerned
about if they were going to register the
car or not
they could get it inspected a month or
two earlier yes absolutely thanks
for further questions representative
manchu putin thank you mr chair thank
you for taking my question um
isn't there a pro rating for
registration at this time so for example
if i sold my car before the registration
that whatever the prorated that would be
yeah yes you would get some credit uh
towards registering another vehicle if
you were to register another one
to replace a vehicle yes you would okay
thank you
i i grew up in maine and i had my first
few cars there and
um the registration and the inspection
took place at the time you bought your
car would you support
that kind of a system where both are
valid you know required immediately and
then annually after that
so it doesn't necessarily coincide with
the owner's birth date um i
i think having them both i i understand
um the previous testimony about hardship
but financial hardship but i i think the
register and inspect in the same month
um
my concern would be is that hey i got it
registered i got four months or five
months before i have to get it inspected
and
somebody actually forgetting about it
and overlooking it that's why i said a
lot of times when you register something
or register a new car
the clerk reminds you that it needs to
be inspected within a certain period of
time
i think that's that's a great benefit to
any further questions
i have one and don't take the strong way
i'm not being sarcastic but how did
the department get over the confusion
when it was every six months and
currently how did you get over the
confusion of even antiques over 40 years
that are every two years and the color
never changes how how do what there's
going to be a way to get around the
confusion well it's just education uh
really and
the amount of doing now granted the
amount of antique cars on the road are
far less than
anything that's within 20 years
so we don't see it that often and
anybody in law enforcement
when we
initially get trained
that's some of what
is presented in the motor vehicle
modules is that hey antiques are every
two years motorcycles are
during the summer months
rv is
a different time of year than the
owners registration month as well
so it's it's a matter of training
more than anything
so so i guess training would probably
take care of this one too so it might
yes okay thank you um any other
questions from the committee
representative hill
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question
when
when those foreigners are in from other
states here do you um
view the inspections from other
uh jurisdictions as well and and check
with license plate stickers and all that
is that
so
uh
yes or no
so for a regular passenger
non-commercial vehicle an out-of-state
plate we would not look at their
inspection
um
their inspection
from our neighbors to the south the
commonwealth
um
their inspection
runs
with their registration
it's
we would not cite somebody from
massachusetts in a passenger vehicle
that was not
inspected
so that's their state's requirement
that's for massachusetts to enforce
massachusetts on the commercial side yes
we would there's a federal
regulation that says the vehicle has to
be inspected
annually
so a commercial vehicle yes we would a
passenger or a non-commercial vehicle
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you mr chairman
uh last to speak
i apologize if i mispronounced steve
zemenek
representing himself in support of the
bill
how'd i do
all right i'm steve samanic uh i'm from
manchester i'm here on my own dime in my
own time
uh and i support this bill um
because of uh
there are people may have multiple
vehicles you know maybe they have a
sports car that they only drive in the
in the summer
and they're
in their birthdays in the
in the um in the winter but also you
know or maybe someone's away out of out
of state for college or what whatever
and it seems very arbitrary but one
thing i've noticed
is that there are a lot of people who
put off their
vehicle repairs until it's time to do
their inspection and the reason they do
this is because they feel like they're
getting screwed every time they go to
get an inspection sticker so they say
well i'm going to give them something to
find
so i'm going to wait until my birthday
to get my tires or breaks or whatever
and
that way they're going to get the whole
year out of it and they're gonna
you know they're not gonna they don't
you know
they're not gonna get the brakes done
and then
three months later they're gonna say oh
well now you need all new tires or uh
suspension rebuild or whatever
so i think that by letting people you
know get an inspection sticker every
time they get an oil change
might actually improve road safety uh
and the safety of the vehicles that are
all right thank you they take any
questions
are there any from the committee
seeing none thanks very much
uh that's the last person i have signed
to speak on
this bill uh is there anybody else
that wishes to seeing that i'll close
just
um
foreign
uh
is
hey
foreign
oh
is
yes
you
okay being 1 30.
i'm going to open up the public hearing
in house bill 1426 fn
eliminating the vehicle inspection
mandate for non-commercial vehicles
chair recognizes representative casey
connolly prime sponsor welcome back to
thank you to the chairman uh and to the
committee and it is good to be back here
before my old
or back with my colleagues from two
prior terms
casey connolly state rep from dover
representing stratford county district
and back with a bill that some members
might remember this is nearly identical
to a bill filed two years ago that
did not get a vote on the house floor it
emerged during the night
before kovit when we had a marathon
session it was
summarily tabled
um but this is uh virtually identical so
what this would do is um it would
eliminate the safety inspection
requirement for non-commercial vehicles
commercial vehicles would still be
required to
uh and that only back up uh
non-commercial vehicles would still need
to do the the annual emissions check if
this were to pass
commercial vehicles would still need to
do a safety inspection and the emissions
check just like
uh just like they do now
and you would discern a commercial
vehicle from a non-commercial vehicle by
one that is
a
something other than a natural person so
that's how you would clear that up
the underlying premise here is that
safety inspections while a good idea
are not something that should be
mandatory and while that might seem
counterintuitive
i mean because right an inspection would
have to make the road safer right well
the data does not show that there's
absolutely no data linking inspections
with better outcomes and better safety
on a roadway
and the congressional budget office is
just the latest
organization to look for a link and not
find one
so first of all there are 36 states that
do not require an annual safety
inspection that number is trending
upward not downward
connecticut and new jersey are among the
most recent states to eliminate their
inspection programs
states with inspections
can have similar climates to new
hampshire one of the things we tend to
hear is that new hampshire is this
um
you know holy uh or it's this
basically what we hear is that we beat
cars up more than any other state due to
climate and salt and bad roads and this
uh this all comes together to
um
beat up our cars well there are other
states that have similar conditions that
that don't have inspection that have
better safety
data than new hampshire that includes
minnesota michigan wisconsin
colorado montana and alaska they have
similar climates they don't have
inspections
in minnesota and ohio and washington
states without inspections
are among the safest states in the u.s
for motorists
but texas louisiana and virginia
inspection and there they have
inspections and they're among the least
safe state for motorists
the national highway traffic safety
administration studied component
failures or the effect of component
failures in more than 2.1 million
crashes
they found that these component failures
things you'd find in inspection were
present in two percent of crashes
uh more than a third of those two
percent were tire failures and that
could come with a new tire or a bald
tire there's no way to know
um driver behavior accounted for 94
percent of crashes driver behavior
the federal congression oh we already
talked about that um so inspections for
all the comfort they offer it's a
snapshot in time it says a vehicle on a
certain day
meets the inspection criteria according
to one shop inspections last for up to
16 months as we just heard
during which time a motorist could drive
you know 1500 miles or 50 000 miles
despite the scarcity of data linking
inspections to highway safety we know
that one in five vehicles in our state
already fail an annual inspection
so that means for weeks or months
or potentially more than a year they're
driving around our state and it's in a
condition that would not pass an
inspection and yet new hampshire still
ranks in the top 10 or 12
each year for road safety
another metric to consider is that new
hampshire does not limit vehicles
into our state that are not inspected so
look around in the summer time
states from vehicles from connecticut
new jersey and much further afield
without inspection are traveling our
roads and as we heard during testimony
for this bill two years ago the state
police has found no link from
uninspected vehicles in our state and
and causing crashes or any other
problems
so
one thing we just heard of is that from
another bill is that
some people are able to look at their
vehicles and and know what's going on
with them i'm not one of those people i
have no idea what's going on with my
vehicle at any time
but most people are are like me
and people in the 36 states without
inspections they're not all mechanics
either
and yet as we know states without
inspections are just as safe or safer
than new hampshire
uh roadways so the key point here is not
that inspections don't have value
it's
they're they're a fine idea it's that
they shouldn't be mandatory
we don't mandate health checkups also a
good idea but we don't require people to
do that
we know inspections hit lower income
residents the hardest
and operating with an expired sticker is
one of the most common infractions for
our state
police
and while most inspection shops in the
state are honest trustworthy some are
not
consumers have no ability to gauge for
themselves whether a repair is needed to
get or whether it's truly necessary to
get the sticker that's not impugning
anyone that's just a fact that's a power
dynamic that puts people at risk of
being abused so finally i'll end this
uh by saying you know i hope you'll
consider this and give it careful
thought
inspections are not a bad idea and and i
would expect that
if and when this the state ever does
away with them you know auto repair
shops would continue to offer a product
to people that would be voluntary and um
and if it's worth it people would do it
if it's not they wouldn't so i'd ask you
to please consider passing this and i'm
representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um i'm saying when
you're talking i'm sitting here thinking
can you think of another service or good
that is provided by the private sector
uh representative thank you for the
question i you know off the top of my
head sitting here a little nervous
presenting a bill i can't but um you
know as it pertains to this this
the short answer is i can't answer the
question
further questions from the committee
representative fenton
representative thank you for joining us
today and thanks for taking my question
um that is a hefty fiscal note
i think that's maybe one of the largest
we've seen in this committee uh how
would we go about making up that money
to the state
representative thank you you're
discussing the 720 000 number
uh in a in a budget of 11 or 12 billion
i think we could find it uh their state
revenue from a sticker is only a few
dollars
and there's no reason to believe that
the short answer is we could find that
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative um the one part that's
sticking out to me in the fiscal note
which i think you addressed but i just
want to make sure that's what you meant
is um it is assumed that inspection
stations will rely on the vehicle owner
to designate if the passenger vehicle is
used in the regular course of business
um
is that where you're talking about that
if a
vehicle is used for business it must be
registered in such a way
i thought i heard you say it but i'm
wanted
thank you for the question so so much of
the inspection program is done via
rulemaking i believe that could be
addressed via rules but there is a
provision in the current law stipulating
or certain things if a vehicle is owned
by a non-person a corporation so we know
that's not a uh
we could make a logical guess that that
would be a commercial vehicle
and i think
it could it could be addressed via rules
you know do you use this as a business
vehicle and if they don't there could be
infractions for for not telling the
truth
you know it could be addressed with
relative simplicity i think thanks
representative sykes
thank you chairman walsh thank you
representative connolly for taking my
question um
i hear your
point about there being being no colla
collaborative information between or
i'm not sure that's the right word that
i want but there's no connection between
inspections and safety
equally is it not true though that
there's no data to tell us
how many
because it can't prove an
unknown
but there could be and have been i
assume crashes
that
didn't happen because cars were
inspected on an annual basis and there's
no data to
know that one way or the other
representative thank you for the
question it's unknowable
but i would look at other states without
inspections and look at the fact that
they have
you know better or higher performing or
whatever you want whatever word you want
to use
just their roads are deemed safer
without inspection so um
you you can't predict a crash or you
can't discuss a crash that didn't happen
but you would look at what other states
further questions from the committee
you mr chair thanks for taking the
question so there's other states that
are examples uh connecticut new jersey
do you also know whether or not since
the owner of the car is responsible
they've elevated any equipment
violations to
crimes like bad breaks being a
misdemeanor
representative thank you i don't know
that answer but i do know that were
someone to violate
um
or to be driving an unsafe vehicle they
could be cited by our state police as
they could currently so if this were to
take effect and you're driving an unsafe
vehicle there is that mechanism to
thank you and in new hampshire do you
get a criminal record out of that or is
it a violation that was the point i was
trying to make
representative i don't have an answer to
that question
further questions from the committee um
representative fenton
thank you for taking my question just to
follow up on that um
unsaved vehicle aspect i had a friend
recently in florida and he sent me a
picture of a dodge caravan with the with
the bumper uh
zip tied on
so that bumper fell off in that state
and caused an accident they wouldn't
attribute it to a state inspection
violation because as you said they're
not accounting or that's how they
account for it but that's
i don't understand how that data would
be accurate if there's no state
inspections a car like that would fail
thank you representative i think i
understand what you're getting at is how
would you characterize the cause of that
accident if the bumper were to cause
another vehicle to cause an accident i
didn't
i didn't look at the methodology of the
data to know how it they would
characterize it
but i think if if a component was in the
roadway that would probably be cited but
again i can't answer that with any
certainty
representative thompson
thank you
representative
for your presentation today the
beginning of your
testimony you said that
you were not a mechanic you really
didn't have an idea of
of what it was all about and i would and
i i believe you also said most people
you thought probably don't
um
if
[Music]
the state police or local police are
able to cite someone
for a violation of for having unsa an
unsafe vehicle how are these people
supposed to know they have an unsafe
vehicle if they don't have a state
inspection or have some sort of an
inspection
um
thank you for the question there's
uninspected vehicles there's vehicles
that fail inspection and then there are
um
vehicles that are clearly unsafe you
could be inspected and you could be
driving
an unsafe vehicle according to the
standards set forth by the state which i
i did i reviewed them two years ago i
didn't review them before this bill so
might be good reading but you could be
inspected in driving a vehicle deemed
unsafe
any other questions from the committee
no
thank you very much just one for clarity
uh this
if this were to pass any vehicle that
needs a missions test will still be
required to go once a year to get that
test completed
hello i'm dick horn from precision
imports founding president of precision
imports and adjunct professor at
manchester community college in
manchester for automotive i have over
50 years experience in the automotive
business in new hampshire
and i've seen a lot of really bad
inspections over the years where cars
were extremely dangerous to be on the
road
and my concern here
my family who
you would think would be tuned into
automobiles
when they have their cars inspected are
often surprised that they have issues
with their car that they didn't know
they have
and these are people that are tuned in
to cars and they've been we've been
doing this since we've had kids we have
four kids six grandchildren
and my concern is these people that
don't feel they need to have an
inspection coming in the opposite
direction with an unsafe car that
concerns me i've been doing
i want to point out that i'm a certified
master
automotive technician and a certified
bosch technician as well
and
there are a lot of cars on the road
today that people don't even know that
they're dangerous it's something as
simple as a
ripped wiper blades
extremely pitted windshield
when you're driving into the sun at the
end of the day
very dangerous and these are things that
can be pointed out
during a state inspection and
i i would bet that most of the people in
this room do not
walk around and look physically at the
wear on their tires
once a week
right i'm i'm sure of that
so
that's pretty much what i have to say
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
next up uh alicia brinson from new car
hello everyone i'm alicia i'm from new
car automall tilton new hampshire i
started off in the industry as an
automotive technician
my license has since expired but i was
formally a licensed inspector
i started with toyota i worked for
toyota for a couple of years i'm pretty
sure a lot of you here have probably
heard of the class action lawsuit in
regards to frames
the amount of rust and corrosion i saw
on many vehicles that we were replacing
frames on was absolutely absurd
i even remember a situation i had one of
my friends he bought a vehicle from
basically private sale i can't remember
exactly where and he had asked if i
could do a state inspection for him so
he came in i put his truck up on the
lift and looked underneath the vehicle
there was black spray paint everywhere
there was actually a spot on his frame
where they had put tin foil and then
spray spray painted black paint over it
when i took off the tin foil i noticed a
hole in his frame probably the length of
my arm
obviously the vehicle was severely
unsafe to drive
he was pretty distraught he was upset
just because they gave him the
impression that the vehicle was safe to
drive it was
deemed well for the road
basically everything had looked into it
checked out everything was kosher and
after i had called that to his attention
he was very upset if you can imagine
purchasing a vehicle that you're
thinking safe to drive putting your car
seats in the back putting your kids in
the vehicle and then gaining the
understanding that your vehicle is not
safe for the road if he were to hit a
pothole at any point in time from the
point that he had picked up his car to
bring it to me to get it inspected that
could have been a very sticky situation
i even recall another situation i had a
gentleman with a tundra he brought his
vehicle in for a state inspection i put
it up on the lift i noticed that his
the strap for his gas tank was severely
corroded it hadn't given away just yet
but it actually gave enough space for
the fuel tank to sag and shift
i noticed witness marks on the fuel tank
and when i called him out there to show
him the damage and the witness marks he
had actually informed me that while he
was towing his camper he was hearing an
abnormal noise that he hadn't heard
before
looking at the vehicle even further i
noticed further
witness marks on the drive shaft so
when he was towing his camper with the
weight of the camper
it actually was causing the fuel tank to
rub against his drive drive shaft
if you can only imagine all the friction
that creates there and the amount of
heat that could have potentially caused
a fire
i don't know the occupants in his
vehicle at that time but obviously that
could have raised a potential to be
severely unsafe for himself and other
people on the road
even just the amount of damage that
would have caused for him and his
livelihood
another situation i recall i was working
on a corolla i had pulled off the wheels
to conduct an inspection so in the state
of new hampshire you have to pull off
one wheel per axle
i remember removing the right front
wheel there was absolutely no brake pad
left the shim that's behind the brake
pad wasn't even existing
when we had informed the customer of the
news she was honestly so distraught even
i was young at the time i have a
daughter now but at that time i didn't
have children but i did see a car seat
in the back and obviously snacks that
her daughter um i'm assuming daughter
because the car seat was pink um had
eaten like just on journeys on the road
with her mother and realistically having
no brakes in the right front like the
front of the car and these were disc
brakes so obviously do they do the most
braking in the front
she was pretty distraught when we gave
her the news she didn't end up doing the
repairs there but she did come back for
reinspection i did notice that there
were aftermarket parts on the vehicle
but even so at least the vehicle was
safe to drive after she gained awareness
that her brakes were deemed unsafe
a prior analogy was made before so it
looks like we're comparing like our
livelihoods so how we go every year to
well some of us i know i don't
personally
but we
we go get our physicals done annually
our general health doesn't affect
everybody else
your vehicle being unsafe to drive you
getting on the road if you have no
brakes where are you going to stop the
car in front of you more than likely
so my general health obviously me taking
vitamins and making sure i stay healthy
doesn't affect anybody else if i were to
die early or if i were to die due to a
mishap due to not having that
yearly
um
i want to call it inspection but you're
like if i didn't go to the doctor
annually that doesn't affect anybody but
me
my family would miss me but it doesn't
affect them directly if i have poor
brakes or my vehicle's unsafe to drive i
hit a pothole or i can't stop
realistically i'm putting somebody
else's livelihood in danger
and that's all i have
thank you very much
any questions from the committee
almost
thanks for coming today and thanks for
taking the question i'm glad you brought
up frame damage so particularly where
trailing arms connect or maybe spring
shackles or other suspension components
can it be the case that
feels just fine until you finally hit
that top hole that's a pothole that
absolutely sometimes it doesn't even
take a pothole depending on how much
rust is there at any moment if those
components were to give away you could
lose steering of the vehicle
and potentially if you're not a
confident driver even for unseen
circumstances i know her initial
reaction to something is to panic and to
not
observe our surroundings to figure out a
safe remedy for a problem so
realistically when you're thinking of
crashing it could be into another car or
something else within the road
any further questions
next up bill gurney gurney's auto
mr chairman
members of the committee thank you for
hearing me
my name is bill gurney i own gurney's
automotive in nashua new hampshire and
milford
i've been in the automotive industry
since i was 16 years old which
makes that 46 years
we've been in business since 1985.
i am a aaz master technician as well and
state inspections is compared to other
states everybody has different rules so
i think that the data are using one
state against the other elves
doesn't always hold water because
someone's inspection in massachusetts is
different from ours so i think we need
to take that into consideration
we talk a lot about the statistics of
states that have inspections and that do
not have inspections
um
i would submit to you that
if we ask
does this law
do inspections make the roads safer
i don't think you could argue that they
make the roads less safe to some point
is that less safe less safe to the point
of one fatality
one person paralyzed
property damage a year i don't know
but i will tell you i see cars that come
in and have come in
with people that take care of their cars
that don't know something is about to go
wrong
coil spring
in a car can break someone hears a noise
they don't take care of it because it
still
rides fairly well
that car does not handle and will not
perform
especially in a
maneuver it needs to make
and be safe it won't
and they could ride like that for
months
without knowing that
so i think statistics are great
but i think we all know that we can all
make statistics say whatever we'd like
so i think i would like you to consider
that
as a professional
i will tell you that
to eliminate state inspections
uh
problematic
for the consumers in this state and for
people's safety
in vermont a couple years ago
there was a gentleman that inspected a
car
in vermont
and um
didn't
perform it properly and there was some
rust
and there was a fatality
if you want to know if i take
inspections seriously in our business
the gentleman inspected that car went to
jail
for negligent homicide
we take it very seriously that we're
dealing with people's
livelihoods
excuse me
their families
their children
that's what's important fixing cars is
what i do
but taking care of people and their
families
is really what we do
if there's any questions i'd be more
than happy to answer them
thank you any questions from the kid
committee
representative manager putin
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
my question is in regards to the
different state inspections
um are they very very different from
state to state some aspects of the
safety inspection that new hampshire has
is that incorporated into the general
inspection in other states which does
not have the two-part
inspection
yes the state of massachusetts for
example when you bring it in there they
don't necessarily take wheels off they
don't necessarily put the cars up in the
air so each state has their own set of
rules i will tell you i think new
hampshire has done a
phenomenal job at policing their own
self and rewriting rules when they need
to be written but when we
finished with the car and we signed that
statement at the end
that's our liability and that's that
person that works for me liability
that's his name that's his integrity on
that and when he signs that that car is
leaving safe it was a little bit a
statement a little while ago that a car
could be inspected and leave unsafe
if that inspection is done properly that
car is leaving
as safe
as it possibly could be
under the rules of the state of new
hampshire so to answer your question yes
the rules between estates are totally
different um from state to state
on the inspection part of it
any further questions
seeing them thank you very much
all right i might leave it with two it's
uh i always say it's the best deal on
main street
because uh you have a professional
technician
check your car over for a fee that is
reasonable to make sure that your family
is safe mr chairman members of the
committee thank you for the time thank
you
next up
steve zemenek
hi my name's steve zamanick
i live in manchester and i'm here on my
i'm an avid do-it-yourselfer i'm not a
professional mechanic
um but i i try to keep my vehicles in
really good shape and on the road as
long as i can
and um
it seems like every year uh
inspection time becomes like this
anxiety
uh producing thing where uh
i don't know what i'm gonna get jerked
around on this year
and uh
i've gone in for you know and it was my
welcome to new hampshire when i moved
from
massachusetts where it just passed
massachusetts inspection moved to new
hampshire
and had a technician
if you can call him that
hammering on my rocker panels until he
finally made a hole and then said
well you you have a rust hole and it's
going to snap in half even though it was
a body-on-frame vehicle
and um it was very very thin sheet metal
that really wasn't structural
and uh i found it uh very
you know and
it
seemed really unnecessary
um
i uh
and it seems like every year
there's something that
uh i hear people get jerked around over
that has nothing to do with safety if
you go through some of the regulations
there are things that uh don't even make
any sense for example you can't have too
many
forward facing headlights if you have
auxiliary headlights
where
it would seem like if you're driving
down rural new hampshire windy roads you
want all the light you can so you don't
but
uh i've i've had my vehicle fail
inspection for breaks
and uh i go to do it myself and take
them off and they are well within the
the limit because they're just trying to
sell a brake job
plenty of other states
don't have inspection plenty of other
states had inspections and got rid of
them
most canadian provinces don't have
inspection stickers
and
i
i ended up working for a uh one of new
hampshire's largest car dealerships um
for about five years not as a technician
or anything but in the business back end
but i interacted with the people in the
service department and the parts
department on a regular basis and i
drove an old truck at the time
and everyone there kind of knew i worked
on my own stuff
and uh kept it on the road but
eventually got to the point where i
finally decided to buy a new vehicle
um
and uh i bought a one-year-old certified
pre-owned uh truck
um off the lot from them
from my from my former employer
uh
when i bought it one of the it had quite
a few miles on it in that one year
period but one of the things they told
me is we put new brakes on it all the
way around
okay
um
so
a couple months after i buy it goes by
because it's my birthday again i need to
go get my inspection sticker
all right first time in my life i got a
new truck it's a warranty everything
should be fine it's got new brakes
uh i get a call i'm up in my office i
get a call from the service advisor when
i dropped it off uh hey steve
you're going to need new brakes new
front brakes to pass inspection
that's funny
because i just bought this vehicle from
you
less than a year ago and one of the
things you told me was it had new breaks
all the way around so either you're
lying to me when i bought it or you're
lying to me now
and
i went down to the service and i
you know hung up the phone ran down the
stairs into the shop and and uh to
basically confront the mechanic or at
least see with my own eyes what's going
on with my truck
um
and i
as i'm walking in the door the
mechanic's putting the sticker on my
truck
um and i say hey what's this i i hear i
need a new front brakes
and he goes oh i didn't say that he
he starts backpedaling and and say uh
but your brakes are wearing unevenly
and
um
they're probably not gonna last as long
as they should so you probably at your
next oil change you're gonna need a new
brake job
so yeah just keep an eye on it
and uh
so i figure well
brake pads have wear indicators
uh
you know even if they're even if they go
if i can interrupt you it sounds like
you've had a predatory experience i've
had multiple predatory experiences but
not necessarily now
i don't want to excuse me excuse me i
just need you to
please get to the point of why we should
do this or not sure um
it sounds like you had a bad experience
i've had i've had multiple bad
experiences i've
so when i see when i hear like 15 of
vehicles are failing inspection every
year and a lot of it's because of brakes
i actually wonder if you go to your
mechanic and he says you need new brakes
did you really need new brakes
and i
i don't want to throw my former employer
under the bus that's not not naming them
uh because it might have just been an
honest miscommunication between a game
of telephone between the
mechanic and the service advisor and me
but they quoted me seven hundred dollars
uh to do the job so a year later when it
come to go do my next inspection sticker
i say well i'm gonna do my next um i'm
gonna do my next uh brake job before i
go for inspection sticker because
they're probably gonna jerk me around on
it
and um
when i take my brakes off
there are still plenty of pad left a
year after i was told i was going to
need to do breaks and i was like
if this is me and they know i work on my
own stuff
if they're pulling this with me
what are they pulling on someone's
grandma who doesn't know any better you
know are they selling her an unnecessary
brake job
and uh the other thing i've i've noticed
is there's really no
proper appeal process if your vehicle
fails inspection and you think it should
um
break jobs where you know or sorry uh
failures for breaks and then the the
pads are still good
and
nothing's really ever done with it
there's no appeal process all you can
kind of do is if someone says you need a
new brake job you've got to go do a new
brake job that's basically the only
thank you very much sir
any questions from the committee
um
jay recognizes
representative
perez did you want to testify now okay
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee my name is maria perez i'm a
state representative for district 23
milford
i'm
here in a position of the bill
i'm a master certified
service advisor
i was an advisor for almost 12 years for
full motor company
and
this bill it would attack
a lot of the safety regulations when
vehicles go through inspection i saw
the many years that i work as a service
advisor there a lot of safety
issues come through the service
department when people get inspection
we're not talking just brakes we're
talking about tires
we're talking about body parts on the
vehicle they get rusted during the
winter time
we live in a new england area with
vehicles they get rostered very quickly
and i see i saw that a lot during the
many years that i worked as a service
advisor so for for that
reason and i know that we need to keep
our people and new hunters safe i'm here
thank you
any questions seeing none thanks again
um
i'm going to go with
carl huddleston from the new hampshire
state police in opposition to the bill
says you're looking for 10 minutes but
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
i represent the department of safety and
we are in opposition of this proposed
legislation um
this is
basically um this is a safety inspection
and it's a minimum standard and the
state standard
for
both tire depth and uh friction material
on the brake is 230 seconds of an inch
which is a 16th of an inch um
given the weather today
a sixteenth of an inch of tread depth
probably would not let you get going on
the highway so this is a very minimum
it's designed to keep people safe
one thing that was noted before
was that
this would differentiate between a
commercial and non-commercial vehicle
and a statement was made that most
commercial vehicles are registered to
accompany unfortunately that's not 100
correct there are many owner operators
that actually register the vehicle to
themselves
maybe a change in administrative rule
indicating that
somebody would have to register a
commercial vehicle to a business
um would have to be done i don't know
whether that's practical or not
um they could also use that to
circumvent the
inspection process on a commercial motor
vehicle so the bottom line is that
this is truly for everyone's safety not
just the person driving the car but the
it's also a consumer protection issue
vehicle gets inspected uh when a vehicle
gets sold it sold either one of two ways
with a valid inspection sticker and a
20-day plate or with an unsafe vehicle
form so again this is one more layer of
protection
for
the consumer
um
part of my duties
over the last 20 years with the
department of safety is we've done
post collision inspections on vehicles
that have been involved in
crashes
and there have been a number of times
where we have found
deficiencies
brake suspension
steering
that caused crashes
again
a state inspection annual state
inspection
may have been able to pick up on those
deficiencies
beforehand
i would gladly answer any questions
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
seeing them thanks again thank you
next up chair recognizes and i apologize
the printing is so small
uh kenneth
rounty
and before you get started it says
you're looking for 15 minutes
in all fairness i just
the average i have here is three to five
all right
um
so we heard a testimony in support of
this bill that gave us a lot of data
showing that uh
there really doesn't appear to be a
relationship between the lack of state
inspections in a state and
the
dangers on the road
um
i'm a data person i think that we should
listen to data first and foremost
um
but if anecdotal evidence you know helps
i can give some of that as well
so
i have an incentive to be
against this bill um because i i also am
a mechanic
um not ase master certified yet but i'm
only three tests away i haven't failed
and
we've heard a lot of horror stories
emotional horror stories about
people who didn't know their vehicles
were in disrepair and they were
discovered at the point of inspection
but what you're not hearing is
we see those vehicles every day even if
they're not coming in for inspection
mechanics have an incentive
when you go for an oil change to look
through your car and tell you if there's
something wrong because they want the
business
so that's the answer to your question
sir you asked earlier
about would would we miss these things
if we didn't have state inspections i
don't think so um
yeah your average person is a mechanic
but they still go for an oil change and
you know to a mechanic who's going to
look through their vehicle and and
you know let's be honest try to find
work
um
so
between the data and the fact that you
know on a day-to-day basis you see these
vehicles whether or not they're coming
in for inspect inspections you're
finding these problems
um
i don't i don't see a reason why this
also you do have some people who are
malicious with inspections or or
even people who interpret the the rules
differently the state wants us to
inspect vehicles the same way every
vehicle gets inspected the same way but
the truth is different mechanics you
know apply their own spin to uh you know
the rules and they don't necessarily
follow them to a tee
um
i've seen cars get that that were failed
for uh
you know
brake pads that that shouldn't have been
failed they don't meet the requirement
that the
and
you know
when you tell a customer that their
brakes are bad they definitely they want
to get it done
they don't want to drive in a vehicle
that's unsafe
so if they don't have the means to check
for themselves i'm sorry let me let me
the horror stories that we're hearing
um
the one thing that they have in common
is because they didn't know
um and they just happened to be noticed
at the point of inspection again they
could have been noticed during an oil
change or any other routine care
um but also
they all wanted to get it done they were
horrified when they heard that their
brakes were in disrepair or there was
some other issue with their vehicle they
you know i think the reason that there
is no data showing
that
state inspections make a difference in
terms of safety on the road is because
when people
hear that their vehicles and safe they
genuinely want to fix it
you tell a mother who comes in with her
you know her kids your vehicle's in
disrepair during an oil change and she's
just as likely to get it done as if it
were a state inspection
and i think that's essentially
all i have to say
chair recognizes tracy borovage from new
hampshire motorcycles rights
thank you mr chair and committee members
for the opportunity to speak
i am tracy borvaj i'm the president of
new hampshire motorcycle rights
organization
some of you i've seen before and some of
you have not so hello to those that i
have not met before
i'm here representing nhmro which is
we're also known by that
besides new hampshire motorcycle rights
organization
we are in opposition of this bill hb
1426 as it includes motorcyclist
um
one of the things i just want to bring
up that's not in my testimony because
you keep hearing data
i was lucky enough this past two years
to be invited to sit in on first of all
i was included
via
legislation the governor to now be on
the highway traffic safety commission so
i now have a seat on that i was also
invited to be on the highway
safety
strategic highway safety planning
commission
almost 24 hours of being on that with
engineers
and the crash data what we found out
just recently there's a lot of it that
has and it's it's not no one's fault but
there's a lot of reporting of crash data
that has holes in it there's a lot of
missing pieces to that
so in that crash data there's a lot of
things that we're finding
that's missing are the mechanical pieces
so as you hear crash data crash data we
are missing crash data that is a
component of this with that whole
mechanical side
we're finding it with the motorcyclist
that's important to me but also with
vehicles so something you might want to
think about
we did hear that we are talking about it
and how to deal with that on that
strategic highway safety planning
commission
and that's something that they do y'all
are probably familiar with it
where we plan for the next five years
what they're going to do with the roads
here in new hampshire it was an awesome
thing to sit in on and be part of and
very honor very honored to be able to be
the motorcyclist to sit in on that thank
you for letting me say that
the last time that an industry survey
was done
where motorcycle inspection failure was
looked at it was 30 to 40 percent
we feel as an organization that's a big
failure rate for motorcyclists
how a rider rides a motorcycle and if
you're not a motorcyclist
you might not understand this but how a
rider rides their motorcycle
is a big component of how a back tire
wears out
how much weight
a rider carries on their motorcycle is a
big component
of how a back tire wears
i know you're aware of our season up
here is short
we have motorcycles that sit all year
long or not all year half of a year
before we can get on them and ride
that's a chemistry part of how that tire
might be once we get on them a ride in
the springtime
i know a lot of riders that get on that
motorcycle and if we didn't have an
inspection would never look at their
tires would never look at their brakes
nor would they know how to measure that
tire tread depth
or look at their brakes to figure out if
they're okay and would get on that
motorcycle and ride
a lot of motorcyclists in this state
ride a couple thousand miles
a lot of them ride
30 to 45 000 miles in our short season
big difference
but all of them still should have their
motorcycles inspected
we have a lot of new riders we have we
have almost 80 000 registered
motorcycles in our wonderful small
little state
we have a lot of new riders in this
state most of them have no clue how to
work on their motorcycles much less how
to look at what they're doing with their
motorcycles
that's important to us as an
organization as well which is another
reason that we believe their motorcycle
should be inspected this is not old
school bikers these are new guys that
get on again their motorcycles and never
look at their tires
huge component for us we only have two
wheels
when we're on the road with other
vehicles
we want to know that their tires and
their brakes are safe obviously
if i'm riding by two vehicles right here
or one in front of me
i want to know if they put on their
brakes
that their brakes are going to work i
don't want them their tires to go and
take me out
another component for us is motorcyclist
one of the things that was mentioned in
this
was the physical note or the physical
note sorry that southern accent comes
out that fiscal note i've been with you
i know that someone says you can make up
that
720 i think it is there's another
what is it 86 000 i think that goes to
the towns
so it's really 800 000
it's got to come from somewhere
but that component on our roads is
important to us as motorcyclists because
probably
even more
than the cars
really good road conditions affect
motorcyclists
if the roads are are not so great i know
in the the state because we've met with
them
they use that crack sealant we call them
road snakes
to repair their roads to make them last
longer
it's very dangerous to us as
motorcyclists so if we're going to take
away some of that money
they may use that more
that's tough for us
so we want to keep that money
going to our roads to make them safer
and lastly i want to leave you on the
back page you've got something i want
you to know
as an organization we're serious about
what we do
you've got our ride smart program
that we started
we incorporated it with the new
hampshire highway of safety
we brought in the writer's education
program we brought in new hampshire
automobile dealers association aaa the
liquor commission
iheart media
and
we started a task force just for this
purpose of looking at how motorcyclists
are affected in this state what we could
do to do better how to educate
motorcyclists and what was important
motorcyclists
keeping the inspection is important to
us
thank you any questions from the
committee
if you'll take any
i don't know is he nice
my wife thinks so
okay
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
testifying today i got a quick question
for you in your notes here you mentioned
motorcycle inspection failure rate of 30
to 40 percent
and you've mentioned you know tires and
brakes what are the things
um is causing some of the failure rates
in motorcycles
so dan bennett is going to speak more to
that that's i mean and i work very very
much with those guys he'll he can give
you more of that detail um i can tell
you from our organization again tires
and brakes are the biggest the biggest
two components for us especially the
back tire and it's just because of how
how we ride
and it and again it depends on every
rider is different you get the hardcore
writer i'm sure you've seen those some
of the ones that we try to get on the
ride like they shouldn't ride
and then you get the you get the full
dressers that fully dress them that have
all of the components to them they've
got the wife on the back or maybe the
husband on the back i don't know
and it's what all that weight with what
they're doing and all the mileage that
they put and what they do on the road
how many miles they go that's going to
wear that tire out a lot more for us
it's it's more about the tire and the
braking systems and with the newer bikes
even with all the newer bikes that
they've got with the abs brakes and that
type of thing there's still more of that
that needs to be inspected for us uh
there's a lot more to the controls and
the newer bikes that that need to get my
my husband's newer motorcycle one of his
motorcycles he's got three um lost a
sensor that he didn't know about we're
on the bike and all of a sudden going up
a hill the sensor let go and it went
room and we almost went backwards down
the hill because of it the inspection
would have caught that but
for us it happened to be that we got on
it before we had the inspection
not something we do anymore
so things like that are important thank
you you're welcome
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
thank you committee and chairman
uh
chair recognizes jeff overdank from the
department of motor vehicles
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee i will not take my full
five minutes after all the testimony
i've heard today just to provide some
data that we pulled out of our
inspection system on wednesday for
today's proceedings
so to answer one of the questions that
was asked earlier what are the
percentages of things that's what we
have here today
and i pulled five years worth of
inspection data out and it's a 15
average for a failure rate so if you can
imagine 1.5 million
inspections done in 2021 and 217
881 violations found and violations
again to go back to the earlier
testimony we heard today
are minimum skill sets i mean they're
minimum rather
minimum sets here i mean 230 seconds is
a failure and tires and brakes
are number one number two categories so
five years worth of data 15
failure rate on average
and i can certainly pass this out if
anybody's interested to see that as well
but this did come from our system
last wednesday
any questions
well
representative gagne
you said 15 failure rate over five years
the average is what you said okay follow
up
how many vehicles inspected over that
time you gave a figure and i didn't get
it i'm gonna pass that out for you oh uh
you can have it i brought enough copies
for everybody but to answer the question
in 2021
uh 1 million 524 thousand 758 vehicles
inspected 1.5 217
881 failures for a 14.29
[Music]
failure rate
and it goes back to
uh again goes back five years ago and we
were at 16 and a half percent
um in 2017.
okay thank you you're welcome
seeing none thank you very much
uh last person i have signed up to speak
dan bennett
representing the new hampshire auto
dealers association opposed to the bill
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i will be brief um it's almost
as bad as being the last speaker before
lunch i guess so um i will hit a couple
points very briefly i'll do my best to
not repeat any that have already been
said by some of the speakers before um
and i will answer uh some of the
questions that i've heard as well
as efficiently as possible so again dan
bennett new hampshire automobile dealers
association uh thank you for your time
today uh we are a trade association
representing over 500 businesses in new
hampshire um in the motor vehicle
industry
both franchise and independent
businesses
so
we are opposed to hb1426 as we have been
in the past
over multiple years
this bill has or this similar concept
has been heard by this committee and it
has been wisely voted down one of the
most recent times it was defeated by the
full house 258 to 70. so
there's always been strong support
against this issue in both this
committee room and the house as well
a few things that we've heard about data
i haven't seen the data that
representative conley has referred to
but we certainly can you provide you
some of the data that we look at
some of the federal data um so nitsa did
a study that looked at vehicle crashes
and said mechanical defects
are an aggravating factor in over 12.6
percent of crashes
that means about 850 000 crashes per
year could be avoided
the pennsylvania d.o.t recently did a
study back in 2009 and they said the
pennsylvania annual program um
has reduced the number of fatal crashes
by 115 to 169
save it which translates to saving uh
127 to 187 lives so if this program has
proved to save even one life i think
it's a value um it's a good program
and it's a really big ask to hope that
people do inspections
so um this this program seems to work
preventative maintenance costs way less
than catastrophic repair
a brake job costs 300 bucks a front end
after that break and ball joint
component failure cost 3000 so this
annual check
actually saves citizens money through
preventative maintenance
all of our neighboring states have
inspections massachusetts maine vermont
we heard about states that have dropped
their inspection programs
i heard the example of new jersey i'll
mention this new jersey dropped their
program in 2010
in a in a budget crisis because it was a
state-run program done through unionized
labor work that cost the state
millions of dollars to administrate it's
not a free it was not a free market
program like new hampshire's is so they
can't really be compared um they're
really they're apples to oranges mr
oberdink did a spectacular job with the
data talking about the 15 percent we
have some um
some some of that same data and we
included in our handout for you all to
see um there's some things going to
refer to in the handout that i sent
around
like visuals
but i would mention this that failure
rate of 15 is likely and at least 15
that is the floor
because in a lot of cases when a vehicle
fails the technician finds it they talk
to the vehicle owner the owner says i
have bad tires go ahead fix them
they don't fail me
then pass me after i've done it they let
me know they go ahead and fix the item
and then the vehicle serves as a pass so
that at that 15 is an at least number um
i think there's there's an issue
was discussed about uh you know personal
versus commercial vehicles um so again
i'd like to point to that handout that
you see there okay
there's a picture of a subaru wagon
there got a nice trailer hitch pull a
camper rocket box to throw skis in a lot
of stickers on it kids favorite sports
team and stuff like that
for law enforcement there is absolutely
no way to know that that vehicle is
owned by the new hampshire automobile
dealers association working compensation
trust
the potential for fraud or uninspected
vehicles that will be on the road that
will be unenforceable by law enforcement
can be problematic
because there'll be no check
so
you've heard from other people that are
agree with us that they are opposed to
this this bill there's others like the
new hampshire traffic safety commission
aaa
and you've heard some from some some of
those other folks
one important component to the safety
inspection program that is automatically
done through the the software and the
program that does it is that when your
vehicle is inspected it receives a
federal safety recall check
through the national highway
transportation safety agency this is a
new component that was added into the
system when the last contract was
reviewed
between june of 2021 and november 2021
so just a few months
this program alerted citizens to over a
hundred and seventy two thousand open
safety recalls
and those recalls are covered by the
manufacturer they're not out of the
pocket of the citizens so there's a real
again i'll go back to my handout you'll
see a little map there okay
because i'd like to talk apples to
apples about new hampshire and our
climate
this is a a
a map that looks at winter severity and
if you look at new england you see we're
we're we're nuclear red so you can't
compare us to other states like florida
arizona california okay but then some of
the states that i even heard from the
representative was ohio washington
michigan and if you look at it
we have much more severe
winters than other states that's why new
england has a microclimate all have
annual inspections because it's good for
the micro climate that we live in
i drove home last night about 8 30 and
you know what they were doing spraying
on the roads right before the
temperature dropped they were spraying
liquid salt water on the roads
okay that's not a practice that's done
in a whole lot of other places when that
gets into the undercarriage of vehicles
and the damage that it's done i think
you heard from an earlier speaker about
um frame damage and corrosion so um
it's a a a very different climate and i
think this map this data kind of proves
that so um
with that being the end of the prepared
testimony that i have for you um i just
like to answer some of the questions or
talk about some of the things i heard
very very briefly um representative
o'hara to your question
the government mandates plenty of
inspections done by the private sector
such as elevators boilers fire
extinguishers gas pumps and don't get me
started on airplanes okay
um so i think that one um representative
gorski uh your question about failures a
lot of the failure items on motorcycles
are pretty similar uh brakes tires
suspensions and lighting um
the one issue that does uh deviate from
that
is motorcycle sound
for any of you have been around this
room for a while you know we're not
allowed to call it motorcycle noise it's
motorcycle sound so there is a decibel
level check done on motorcycles
to make sure that they're below a
certain level and that's a common
failure item because motorcycles are so
i heard a comment about we'll catch
these things during oil changes
at an oil change you do not pull tires
you do not aim headlights uh you don't
measure ball joint gauges at the frame
and suspension connection so um
these things are
it's a it's a very different review and
then the last thing that i'll mention is
i heard about this no there's no appeal
process if there's a safety inspection
failure
and it's not the case the safety
inspection failure is a notification
you don't have to hold someone there and
they can't leave and you're keeping
their keys unless they fix it and
they're not allowed to leave it's not a
hostage situation um it's a it's a
safety failure notification okay and
then there's troop g and the state
police and their team of automotive
equipment inspectors
that in instances of that uh you know
alleged violation or a grievance
they are responsible for coming down
reviewing inspecting and investigating
whether that is a valid claim or not so
there is a process through the state
police through their troop g to review
instances like that so um
those are the um
the only items that i wanted to address
from previous testimony
and then if there are any questions
i'll do my best to see if i can
any questions from the committee
representative mancha putin
thank you mr chair a quick question in
terms of um
when an insp
vehicle fails the safety inspection is
there a time frame within which or do
you uh
assess it based on the severity of the
safety concern
if it's a minor
you have this longer is there a set
process for that
uh thank you for the rep question
representative uh no there is no graded
scale or hierarchy that says uh a window
chip needs to be done in five and a horn
needs to be done in ten they're all
treated the same the the thirteen basic
safety related mechanical items that are
inspected all have the same time frame
a quick follow-up missed
follow-up
um
is there a time frame so for every the
13-point inspection
and it fails one or two you have
the inspections are done within the
birth month of the
individual and i believe
they
are extended 10 days into the month
following that inspection month expires
state police will throw a book at me
from the back of the room if i'm
incorrect but
i believe that's correct that they get
10 days into the next month and then
that sticker expires and it's dead and
seeing none thank you very much thank
you mr chairman and member of the
committee the last person i have signed
to speak on house bill 1426 is there
anybody else that wishes to
see now i'm going to close the public
hearing
uh for those i see a few in the room i
do have an executive session scheduled
for 2 30.
that did go a little longer than i
thought so we are going to need a little
bit of time to regroup
uh you know how it works representative
so
okay welcome back sorry for the delay
just trying to get organized
actually not trying to getting organized
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1160 relative to
obedience to signals at railroad
crossings
the chair recognizes representative
tallersky
thank you mr chair i'd like to make a
motion about to pass on house bill
motions ought to pass is there a second
seconded by representative hill
care to speak to your motion
um
motion is ought to pass this is open for
further amendment uh do you have no have
a motion i do i would uh direct your
attention uh to an amendment i have
distributed
h
is there a second on the amendment
okay
would you care to speak to your
amendment sure
um
as we heard last week this is really a
bill about
rail track safety
and i think when we first heard the bill
most of us were quite amenable to it
although the department
wanted to clarify
that this does not include recreational
equipment the amendment just adds the
phrase or other maintenance of way on
track equipment
at each spot throughout the bill to
clarify that it's for
utilitarian
fair enough thank you any other
discussion
seeing none on the amendment with no
other discussion we'll do that by voice
vote um all those in favor of amendment
zero two zero two two zero four nine
three
signify by saying aye
opposed nay
okay
the amendment is adopted
uh the motion now is ought to pass as
amended on house bill
1160.
um is there any other discussion on the
bill
seeing none um i'll ask the clerk to
call the roll whenever she's ready
vice chairman gagne yes
representative smith
yes
clerk votes yes representative hill
yes representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg
representative gorski
yes representative o'hare yes
representative aaron yes representative
scott sykes yes
representative amanda poodie no was that
good thank you
yes you got it
uh representative fenton yes
representative rambo yes representative
rich yes representative tillerson yes
representative fox yes representative
perez
yes
representative
19-0
19-0 i think so okay the committee
recommendation about to pass as amended
has adopted 19-0 i already heard a
motion for consent is that seconded yes
though without objection consent it is
so i'll close the executive session on
1160.
uh
i'm
you waiting for me yeah oh i'm good oh
sorry
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1239 fn
chair recognizes representative o'hara
for a motion
thank you mr chairman i move itl on
12 40. this is 39. sorry 12 39 uh otp
sorry okay okay well yeah motions ought
to pass on 12 39 is there a second
second seconded by representative gagne
uh bill's open for further amendment
chair recognizes representative
tallersky for a motion
thank you i would like to bring your
attention to an amendment that's been
okay
is there a second on the amendment
was that was that yes by travis
represent
uh i will briefly um
mr casco of uh dos supplied us with this
verbiage
there were two options this i think is
was if i remember correctly the more
minimal uh
version
which still allows them to use first
class mail clarifying
the address
that puts the onus on the driver that
they need to update their address with
the division of motor vehicles but it
also um
requires that a default order shall be
served in hand so that there can't be
the misunderstanding
moving forward
i hope that clears up some of the
questions that we had yep thank you it
seems like we struck a good balance any
seeing none
do the amendment with a voice vote uh
all those in favor of amendment zero
five zero eight h signify by saying aye
aye opposed nay
okay
the amendment is adopted
uh motion on the floor now is ought to
pass as amended on 12 39 anybody cared
seeing none representative
i'd like to speak in favor of the motion
as ought to pass as amended it's um what
i would characterize as a reasonable
compromise um and that it
it also has the further balance of
protecting the rights of the individual
for a fair
fair process
and as i said i agree completely with
nothing else i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
uh as soon as she's ready
vice chairman gagney yes
representative smith yes clerk votes yes
representative hill yes representative
thompson yes representative ankerberg
yes representative gorski yes
representative o'hare yes representative
aaron yes representative sykes
yes
representative
mangiapoody
yes
representative fenton yes representative
rambo yes representative rich yes
representative tillerson yes
representative fox yes representative
perez
perez sorry
you say yes
do you say yes thank you representative
yes and chairman walsh
19-0 yes
190 okay so the committee uh
recommendation about the pass is amended
as approved 19-0 i already heard consent
by representative gagne is there a
second
okay representative thompson any
objection to consent yeah just a
question for the chair isn't it usually
the when there's an fn
uh depends on the value of it okay and
what we usually do here is at least give
our wishes to the clerk if he tells me
i'm wrong and it has to go on the
regular calendar so be it
thank you for clarifying yeah but i
believe most of the
fiscal notes that were large enough have
already been disposed of as early bills
so this could go either way
[Music]
so i'll close the executive session on
house bill
fm
okay i'll open up the executive session
on house bill 1240 fn uh chair
recognizes
representative gagne for a motion
thank you mr chairman
i would move itl on house bill 1240 fn
it'll is there a second
second by representative o'hara
care to speak to your motion
yes sir uh on line seven of this bill
it says that the changes a defendant
shall be presumed to have been served
three days after mailing of the notice
i don't like the word presumed
you can't presume anything
you know you're assuming that something
has been done it may not have been done
therefore
anybody else wish to speak to the itl on
12 40.
representative sex
so it might not escape the notice of
some people that i actually was the
co-sponsor of this bill but when i
signed off on this bill as a co-sponsor
i would just venture to say that the
post office then in the post office now
is two very different things
and
based on that i'm willing to support the
itl motion
thank you sir anybody else wish to speak
thank you mr chair i agree with
representative sykes even though you see
my name on the bill a thing that's
happening to me right now
i mailed a package to a guy in attleboro
massachusetts i probably could have
driven it there in two or three hours
two weeks later now he knows it was
coming because i emailed him and told
him it was coming and he even gave him a
tracking number and he still hasn't
gotten it and the post office told him
well wait another week and if it doesn't
show up then have the sender put in a
claim we can't have a presumption of
three days if it was three months i
might go for it
thank you representative smith and as
the prime sponsor of the bill i agree
i agree with both my
my colleagues so
uh any other discussion on house bill
representative hill i think we need to
point out that the person that made the
motion worked for the post office at one
time
that was the old post office
the new one is way different
all right any other discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role when she's ready
vice chairman gagne yes representative
smith yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
o'hare yes representative aaron yes
representative sykes yes representative
mangipudi
yes
representative fenton
representative rambo yes representative
rich yes representative telersky yes
representative fox yes representative
perez
yes representative ayo
yes and chairman walsh
yes 19-0
mr chairman
okay the committee recommendation of itl
19-0 is adopted i've heard a
motion for consent is there a second
represented seconded by representative
o'hara with no objection consent that is
seeing that i'll close the executive
session
i'm going to open up the executive
session on house bill 1573 relative to
prohibitions on driver's licenses
chair recognizes representative o'hara
for a motion
thank you mr chairman i move itl on
1573. it'll's been moved is there a
second second seconded by representative
gagne
care to speak to your motion yeah just
briefly thank you mr chairman um senate
bill 311 is a more comprehensive bill
that addresses the same issue
so i feel like that'd be a better bill
for us to work on
fair enough any further discussion
on
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
vice chairman gagney
yes representative smith yes clerk votes
yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
o'hare yes representative aaron
yes representative sykes yes
representative manjuputi yes
representative fenton yes representative
rambo yes representative rich yes
representative talarsky yes
representative fox yes representative
perez
yes representative
yes and chairman walsh yes
19-0
19-0 committee recommendation of itl has
adopted 19-0
motion for consent by representative
herrera seconded by gagne
without objection consent it is
i'll close the executive session on
um
so this is where we're at
i did schedule
house bills 1463 1666 fn and 1093
for today but we're not going to be
taking them up today
we've actually been working very hard
here in committee we're ahead of
schedule comfortably
i think we deserve to get out of here at
a reasonable hour for a change
um
i had mentioned last week the plans that
i had were to take the week of well next
tuesday the 15th off because we're going
to be in session for two days or a day
and a half
and then then schedule the remainder
remaining four bills
uh for the 22nd that has not changed
because i'm uncertain of how many people
we're going to have at that last
hearing we're going to go into some sort
of executive session but i don't know if
it'll be long enough for us to finish
them all
we probably will be stuck coming back
one more day to do
housekeeping basically on any bills we
haven't exact yet there is also one more
moving part and that's a senate bill
that's being fast-tracked our way which
i heard
we're going to be receiving on the 22nd
which would mean i couldn't schedule it
to hear it on the 22nd anyway so i think
our our our hand has already been played
for us that we're going to need another
day
and so
they're in there in our there's our
mop-up day for any uh executive sessions
a perfect plan
[Laughter]
no next week we're not going to meet
um we met we we we got all our early
bills done we're ahead of schedule
comfortably with only four bills
remaining about five
so
we'll stop here tonight
and i'll see you in manchester next week
you